make sure you guys hit the Subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and uh
make sure you guys hit the like button
if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
okay so continuing our Spiderman week
coverage we pick up with the Ultimate
Spider-Man and the origin of Miles
Morales is the best way to say it Miles
Morales appeared before this particular
origin but uh he was really just kind of
like a kid who was there and that was
really about it and this is interesting
because this brings in really to like
Spider-Man homecoming the idea of Miles
Morales this video is being made two
weeks before Spider-Man homecoming so I
have no idea what goes on in that movie
but I would surmise that Miles Morales
will probably appear in the movie but
either he'll be a post-credits scene or
he'll just be a kid who's mentioned and
that'll be about it and the reason why
that works is because of the fact that
that's what happened in the Ultimate
Universe this whole origin came after
Miles Morales first appeared prior to
this he was just a kid who was there and
that was really it there was no
expectation that he was going to grow
into anything or become anything
significant and it was kind of
interesting because to me there are a
lot of aspects of Spider-Man homecoming
that pull directly from the Ultimate
Universe and it's always been that way
with the Marvel Cinematic Universe the
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is rooted
more in the Ultimate Universe than it is
in the main Marvel continuity there are
some differences I mean there are some
main Marvel timeline things that are
folded in for example Captain America
Steve Rogers is the first super soldier
in the main Marvel Universe but he's not
the first super soldier in the Ultimate
Universe and that actually brings us in
to the story of Miles Morales origin and
the reason why is because of the fact
that all of this basically deals with
Norman Osborne and Osborne Industries as
well as something called the oz formula
now the oz formula is just one of
several attempts in the Ultimate
Universe to basically duplicate the
original Super Soldier serum that made
Nick Fury and this is one of the biggest
differences when it came to the Ultimate
Universe and the main Marvel Universe
with regards to the main Marvel
continuity you have what's called
weapons plus and weapons plus is
basically just this organization that
serves the purpose of creating super
soldiers to battle against credible
threats the idea was that Captain
America Steve Rogers was weapon one that
was it but because of the fact that Dr
Abraham Erskine the guy that was behind
the formula that made Steve Rogers into
a super soldier had basically been
killed it was impossible to duplicate
his formula per perfectly and so the
idea was to try to attempt it but if it
didn't work to also have backup projects
instead and so what we got were projects
two through nine and that was everything
from like you know implanting cybernetic
implants and like animals trying to make
animals sentient it was a multitude of
just different things it all had to do
with creating super soldiers eventually
it led into weapon 10 or Weapon X which
gave us Wolverine which led into like
Deadpool and you know all different
kinds of stuff but all of it was rooted
in the idea of Captain America Steve
Rogers in the Ultimate Universe it's a
wholly different kettle of beans the way
it all worked out is that instead of
Steve Rogers Nick Fury was the very
first super soldier but much like
Captain America Steve Rogers in the main
Marvel Universe the entire basis behind
the super soldier serum had basically
gone up in smoke nobody really knew how
to replicate it but what ended up
happening is different organizations
across the world began attempting to
duplicate it of course in Canada for
example they were trying to duplicate
the process that made Nick Fury into a
super soldier and that resulted in them
kidnapping James Hallett and discovering
the X Gene which meant that if these X
genes were basically unlocked or they
were accessed people would be granted
powers and so once they access the
powers of James Hallett then they in
turn turn this formula or what have you
into an aerosol form dispersed it across
the world and that's how mutants started
popping up when it came to Norman
Osborne and Oz the oz formula that was
based off the super soldier formula that
was used to make Nick Fury into a super
soldier and so the idea was that Norman
Osborne was trying to find a way to
again create super soldiers and in doing
so began the process of like radiating
spiders and so on and so forth one of
these spiders bit Peter Parker which led
to the start of the Ultimate Spider-Man
line of stories now that deals with the
idea of like mutants and most of the
super-powered community the idea was
that in the Ultimate Spider-Man comics
Peter Parker had just gone forward you
know as a superhero and he was learning
about his powers with great power must
come great responsibility then he was
taught by Uncle Ben fast forwarding over
the course of his publication history
once we got into like 2011 2012 writer
Ryan Michael Bendis wanted to shift
things up he wanted to basically remove
Peter Parker and put somebody in place
the fact remains here that in the
instance of Peter Parker effectively
getting away the idea of Osborne was to
basically figure out what it was about
the formula that gave Peter Parker
powers in the first place and then
duplicate it now of course this all dead
ends into the idea of Norman Osborne
being revealed as the Green Goblin and
so on and so forth but then we actually
pick up with a guy by the name of
Prowler now in the main Marvel line of
stories Prowler is a guy named Hobie
Brown and you may have heard of his line
of comics he got his own solo series as
part of all new all different Amazing
Spider-Man's clone conspiracy really the
the biggest role that Hobie Brown plays
an all-new all different Marvel is he's
the stand in Spider-Man when Peter
Parker is you know holding a press
conference or when he's in the middle of
a meeting or something like that Hobie
Brown is the one that parades around is
Spider-Man so that people believe that
Peter and Spider-Man are two distinctly
different people here in this Ultimate
Universe line of stories he's basically
just the uncle of Miles Morales he's
just a guy and they call him Prowler
because he's basically just a guy that
steals stuff but breaking into Osborne
Industries has its own risks in the
sense that you're basically breaking
into a multinational corporation not
only that in the middle this Heist the
spider manages to make its way onto
Prowler which in turn enters his bag
taking this spider with him now from
here we pick up with Miles Morales and
that's one of the things that I like the
most about miles is that Miles the way
his story was told the way it was done
by Brian Michael Bendis he was designed
to basically be a character that
reflected the real world and most of the
Ultimate Universe was like that the
Ultimate Universe was Marvel coming
along and saying okay how can we take
these characters that everybody knows
and everybody loves and update them for
the modern day so they could basically
get an answer to the question what if
Captain America emerged right now that
was the whole basis behind the Ultimate
Universe back when it was made in the
year 2000 and so the idea is that Miles
Morales is basically in a lottery for a
charter school there was a good
documentary that was done a while ago
called Waiting for Superman he said
either is Waiting for Superman or
waiting on Superman but the idea was
that it dealt with like the American
school system and something that a lot
of you guys may not know is that in a
lot of like inner city schools and
really impoverished parts of the country
you'll have like the public school
system and then they'll open a charter
school which is like where you can get
the best education in that particular
school district and they'll hold
lotteries like people will go to like
these huge assembly halls and they'll
basically start drawing numbers and
those kids who were selected get to go
to that Charter School the others are
just left to deal with the American
school system I mean it's one of those
things where it's like if they win and
they get to go to a charter school
they'll have a future outside of
whatever education they get from the
American school system being as defunded
as it is so it's not really designed to
be like a political statement it's
designed to make Miles Morales relatable
and that's one of the things that I kind
of feel like needs to be said especially
right now in Marvel because a lot of
people are looking at the whole you know
political landscape and so on and so
forth this was written back in 2011 and
so while Brian Michael Bendis does have
a tendency to be a little political with
his writing this was not designed to be
a statement he was basically designed to
say here's a relatable aspect of Miles
Morales because there are kids that deal
with this every day of their life in
inner city areas so again it's kind of
cool here because as a kid who is part
Hispanic part African-American it really
related to a lot of young people who
were reading his Comics because that
really feeds into the nature of
Spider-Man keep in mind Peter Parker's
Legacy was formed by the fact that he
basically empowered teenagers he made
young people feel like they were the
star of the show and that Legacy of
Spider-Man lives on because you get a
little bit of the humor but you also get
that whole back story in terms of
everything that happened that made him
who he was and so with Miles Morales
winning this we're basically introduced
to the idea of his uncle miles does not
know about the role that his uncle plays
in being a thief or him his uncle is
just an uncle and so it's really just
kind of Miles relaying the news and and
that kind of thing but the funny
scenario about this too is that Miles
was really told in a lot of ways do not
go see your uncle his father had
explicitly lay that out do not go see
him on the regular he is not a good
influence now of course again the whole
idea of a thief but we'll actually learn
there's a little more about miles dad
than we were originally given there's a
little bit of an expansion here but of
course in the middle of all this he's
basically bitten by the radioactive
spider that his uncle had carried home
and then suddenly just wakes up now of
course with Miles dad coming home
screaming at it you know at his brother
and that kind of thing miles basically
just takes off now this is when we start
to get into a lot of the aspects of
Spider-Man homecoming just kind of going
by the trailer just looking at what
we've seen you know with regards to the
trailers and the whole idea here is that
Spider-Man homecoming looks as though
it's just supposed to be rooted in like
the modern day it's supposed to be
rooted in a lot of like current things
that go on right now again sort of
feeding into this Ultimate Universe
thing but the introduction of it all
really kind of comes by way of Miles
whole experience and learning that he
has powers the other half of this is
that when Brian Michael Bendis made
Miles Morales had he gone through and
made miles just a total replica of Peter
Parker it would have cheapened it it
would have taken away the the impact of
Miles being Spider-Man with miles one of
the biggest issues that he faces is a
combination of just kind of growing up
you know as being a teenager and also
the idea of having powers because
remember one of the relatable aspects of
this is just Teenage life and I don't
know about you guys I don't know how
many of you guys watching this are
teenagers but being a teenager I mean in
hindsight it's the easiest thing in the
world but at the time when you are a
teenager it seems like the hardest thing
in the world because you're trying to
make friends you're trying to be
socially acceptable you also want to be
able to drive around and have your own
independence but you also recognize
you're not necessarily ready for the
world but you think you are there's a
million things that go on in your head I
mean there's College there's your future
there's a million things rolling around
in your head to say nothing of the fact
that you're basically spending you know
five or six years going through an
existential crisis who are you where are
you going what's your purpose in the
universe I mean these are all the things
that teenagers deal with on a regular
basis and so this combined with the idea
of the sudden introduction of powers
makes things a little difficult now the
other half of this is a character by the
name of Genki and this is really the
whole idea of like Ned Leeds character
being brought in to Spider-Man
homecoming one of the funny situations
and one of the things that fans
immediately caught on when it came to
the trailer of Spider-Man homecoming is
the character of Ned leaves historically
speaking in the Peter Parker Spider-Man
line of stories in the main Marvel
Universe Ned Leeds was a bit was like a
like a competitor at The Daily Bugle he
was never a classmate of Peter Parker
with this introduction of Ned Leeds in
Spider-Man homecoming it's basically
Genki from the Ultimate Universe in the
sense that the two of them relate to
each other in the exact same way Genki
is kind of like the the comedic sidekick
he's the kid who sort of cheer
Spider-Man or you know cheers might as
well and it says look man like you're
capable of incredible things but it's
also the idea that Genki is going to be
the moral compass for Miles Morales in a
lot of different ways but it's kind of
cool because instead of just like being
terrified instead of being afraid it's
this idea that Miles could achieve
something pretty incredible with the
powers that he has and so in the middle
of this whole conversation that he has
you know with with Genki he's basically
pulled aside by his father you know
taken to a local park and his father
basically explains the reason why he
doesn't want miles spending time with
his uncle is because of the fact that
his uncle's a thief and that's one of
the greatest things about this
particular story is because with Peter
Parker Spider-Man in the main Marvel
Universe it's well Uncle Ben died and
then with great power must come great
responsibility and the moral lessons
that came with that with Miles Morales
it's a lot more visceral it's this idea
that his father basically made a lot of
bad decisions his father stole at one
point in time his father served time in
jail somewhere along the line for him he
looks at his son miles and says you've
just been accepted to a charter school
you have a future you can get out of
this place but this also creates a bit
of a contradiction with Miles himself
because in his mind it is Imagination he
sees himself being Spider-Man he sees
himself crawling on walls which he
inevitably does he sees himself saving
the day and that's one of the
interesting things about this story is
because you know once he goes and visits
you know Genki and kind of tells him
everything that's going on you know kind
of expands on the idea that he can crawl
on walls and so on and so forth and once
he actually travels you know alongside
Genki and comes across a fire in a
building this creates the kind of inner
debate you know with Miles Morales
between what his father's teaching him
and what he's coming to understand on
his own his father is looking at the big
picture but his father doesn't know that
Miles has spider powers so in the mind
of Miles father it's here's my son who
lives in a pretty rough part of town
who's just been accepted to a school
that will get him a future think of all
the things that he could do he'd become
a lawyer or a doctor or a businessman or
something along those lines in the mind
of Miles Morales with the powers that he
has he can save people on the ground
level and that is the inherent
difference between what it is that Miles
father's teaching him and what miles can
become miles father is talking about
playing a much bigger role playing a
much larger role but when you're
Spider-Man you know when you are on the
ground floor when you're saving somebody
from a burning building you don't say
well hey we're passing some laws and
it's going to make people's life better
and it does instead you see their faces
you see their immediate reactions you
get thank yous you get wow I can't
believe you pulled that off you get the
Adoration of a community that comes to
respect you as you're able to do things
that make their lives tangibly better
that's the coolest thing about that is
because it makes it more personal and so
the struggle that Miles faces is that
where he does rescue a kid from a
burning building suddenly the gravity of
the situation begins to hit him because
now he realized he just saved the human
life and what that means is people will
look at him and they will say wow that
guy's a superhero man that kid's amazing
I can't believe he pulled that off but
now miles has to come to the realization
that the life of other people is in his
hands what if he hadn't acted that
little girl probably would have burned
to death in that building but with Miles
Morales stepping in and saving her life
then the question becomes well what
about the lives that he inevitably just
can't safe well there's just not enough
time for him to get there what about the
person who's being mugged or being
attacked that he doesn't know about how
does all that play into the equation
Peter Parker Spider-Man and the main
Marvel Universe deals with that by
realizing that while he tries to save
everybody he can he cannot save everyone
you can't be everywhere it wants that's
one of the reasons why superior
Spider-Man was so cool because he was
everywhere at once he had eyes all
throughout the entire city but with
Miles Morales he's coming to realize
that you can't be everywhere at one time
you can't save everyone there are some
people out there that you just can't do
anything with and so what we end up
doing is we basically pick up with the
moment by which Peter Parker ends up
dying in the Ultimate Universe and again
this was a pretty big moment in the
whole ultimate Spider-Man story just
because you gotta remember I mean the
Ultimate Universe was basically launched
with Peter Parker Spider-Man and so for
about a decade or so if you were reading
Ultimate Spider-Man you were reading
Peter Parker and the way that he went
out was actually pretty amazing I mean
it was like this battle with Norman
Osborne and you know he basically fought
to the point that he died he was almost
like the superman-esque scenario where
he was basically just like a battle to
the death but in the midst of all this
what it does is it basically sets the
groundwork for Peter Parker to be
removed from the entire Spider-Man
Mythos and it allows Miles Morales to
effectively take his place now something
to point out here is that with Miles
being on the scene and directly you know
speaking with Gwen Stacy When Stacy
really just kind of in a moment of of
mourning sort of spits out the name of
Peter Parker but what it does is it
basically kind of Lights this fire in
Miles Morales because with Miles Morales
seeing everything happen when he sees
the death of Peter Parker he really just
kind of looks at this and says well now
it's up to me to do something his
discussion with Genki is look I didn't
get these Powers even if that got him by
chance I have to believe if anybody had
these Powers they would put them to use
they would live up to the Legacy as it
was created by Spider-Man they would
live up to everything it was that he did
that Peter Parker had effectively done
and so in the mind of miles that's when
he begins to really understand what it
is that he's meant to do the
significance of the world that he plays
in being Spider-Man because going to the
funeral of Peter Parker speaking with
Aunt May speaking with Gwen Stacy is
basically this question that he asked
why did he become Spider-Man what was
the motivation of it and this is the
beauty of this because Gwen Stacy
immediately as angry as she is goes and
basically says he did everything that he
did because his uncle instilled in him
with great power must come great
responsibility those with the power to
act have the responsibility to act and
that is one of the reasons why the
Spider-Man Mythos has always been so
great and one of the reasons why it's so
important when it comes to different
superheroes over the years they all have
their own moral compasses their own
motivations for why it is they do the
things they do with Superman it was this
idea that he was taught by Jonathan and
Martha Kent if you have the power to
stop crime you should stop in some form
or fashion it was always this measure of
responsibility but with the infamous
phrase with great power must come great
responsibility it made it tangible we've
all heard that right like do the right
thing even if no one is watching or
something along those lines we've all
had that moral compass instilled in us
but to have Gwen Stacy say this to Miles
Morales in this way it lights a fire in
Miles Morales because he's just like
that's true it's an honest statement I
have these abilities and so in his mind
while he goes through and Designs his
own little spider Spider-Man suit the
idea is I have to keep the memory of
Spider-Man going and this is actually
one of the first mistakes that he makes
because what they do is they grab a
Spider-Man Halloween costume and he
immediately takes to the streets now
this is one of those things worse just
too early bro it's just it's just way
too early despite miles moral Alice
wanting to do the right thing his
heart's in the right place the mistake
that he makes is that everybody looks at
him as trying to be like a copycat of
Spider-Man but people are still in the
morning phase you got to keep in mind
with the idea of Spider-Man losing such
a hero in such a tragic way people
aren't ready to see somebody just
suddenly take up the mantle they're not
ready to see somebody just suddenly
become Spider-Man what they want is time
to grieve what they want is time to
mourn and once that time has passed then
they'll be ready for somebody to take up
the mantle and so at this point it's
just too much too fast and so in the
middle of this whole experience that he
has running around the streets dressed
as Spider-Man he's basically met with
the arrival of Jessica Drew now Jessica
Drew is actually a pretty interesting
character in the realm of Marvel Comics
and the reason why is because she
originally appeared in Marvel Spotlight
in 1977 I think it was and she was
actually a character who basically
gained her spider powers by way of a
direct injection from her father and it
was really just a weird circumstance it
was essentially that she had just been
you know irradiated by uranium that was
you know across the land and so on and
her father basically tried a cure of her
uranium poisoning by injecting her with
a serum that was composed of different
spiders and then putting her in this
sort of evolution chamber that was
created by the high evolutionary who
messed around with the evolution of
animals and stuff like that she woke up
something like decades later and
basically kind of emerged with no idea
who she was and eventually joined a
Hydra or something like that but with
the Ultimate Universe it's a wholly
different kettle of beans and so Jessica
Drew in the Ultimate Universe is
actually a clone of Peter Parker and
that's one of the interesting things is
because with her character despite
people knowing who she was she wasn't so
significant in the realm of Marvel
Comics that they kind of had to tiptoe
around and be careful about what they
did she wasn't Captain America she
wasn't Thor she wasn't like Iron Man or
anything like that and so because of
that it offered marveled a little bit of
leeway in terms of what they did with
her character how they wrote her how
they designed her so on and so forth
also because of the fact that the clone
saga from Marvel Comics was not a very
well received story for a lot of people
and so the idea of going back and
reworking it in the Ultimate Universe
was actually kind of cool it was
actually pretty interesting but with her
confronting Miles Morales this comes by
way of the fact that she was basically
told by Nick Fury there's somebody out
there impersonating Spider-Man that
happened within you know the a wholly
separate line of stories but the fact
remains that with Nick Fury basically
being the director of shield and then
essentially having all this information
on the life in Times of Miles the cool
thing is that there's a conversation
that takes Place between the two of them
you know where Nick Fury basically says
look I know your heart's in the right
place I know you're trying to do the
right thing but people are not ready for
a new Spider-Man yet give them time give
them a little bit of time they'll come
around but for right now all they see
you as is a cheap knockoff because
you're wearing the exact same uniform
that Spider-Man wore so if you are going
to be Spider-Man if you're going to be a
superhero then you've got to be
different you can't just be Peter Parker
you've got to be your own character and
that was kind of like an in comic book a
statement by Brian Michael bendus
effectively saying Miles Morales is his
own character he's wholly different from
Peter Parker they're two distinctly
different characters and that was one of
the interesting things is because again
it was hitting home at the idea that he
basically sort of gone away and so what
ended up happening is that you know of
course with Electro Maxwell Dylan
basically being one of the most notable
villains of the Ultimate Spider-Man
making his Escape Miles Morales is
single-handedly responsible for
basically being able to bring him down
now the ultimates are there you know the
ultimate Universe Avengers are there and
they do what they can but it's really
miles more hours that pulls it off
through a combination of his ability to
make himself visible and the fact that
he issues this sort of electrical touch
or whatever it is that he engages
somebody now the reason why that works
is because what it does is it basically
sends the electrical impulses of Electro
into overdrive and really just sort of
hyper drives him and then just shuts
them down he's basically overwhelmed by
his own powers but you know with him
being shot dead by Nick Fury as a way to
kind of curtail his character a little
bit what happens is it's basically might
as well showing the ultimates that he's
actually pretty legit
you know he's got what it takes to not
only be a member of the team but to also
stand on his own two feet as his own
superhero now at this point he's not
part of the Ultimate Avengers yet I mean
he hasn't really been rolled in as part
of the ranks just because one he doesn't
have the experience and two they just
don't know enough about him but the
first step to allowing the the ultimates
to gain more information about him to
see what he's about is you know really
comes by way of Nick Fury who presents
Miles Morales with an actual Spider-Man
costume based on Miles own designs when
he was just kind of drawing up these
little versions of his own costume when
he was trying to figure out what he was
going to look like Nick Fury basically
used Shield's resources found this
design I don't know broke into his home
I have no clue but took this costume
made it real and gave it to Miles and
said now go forward and be your own
superhero
okay so getting into Ultimate Spider-Man
or I guess really miles more Alice
Ultimate Spider-Man one thing I want to
point out here is that in these video
titles I'm simply going to call these
Miles Morales Ultimate Spider-Man and
Neil volume 1 volume 2 volume 3 and so
on really the origin story that we did
is volume one so this is more like
volume two but in truth this was really
just kind of called Ultimate Spider-Man
and then there was another series later
on that followed this that was called
Miles Morales Ultimate Spider-Man but in
order to avoid confusion between
Ultimate Spider-Man Peter Parker and
Ultimate Spider-Man Miles Morales we're
just gonna call this Ultimate Spider-Man
Miles Morales so that way everything's
pretty clear and pretty easy to follow
but the cool thing about this is that
again the origin story for those of you
guys who are just joining us with
regards to the whole ultimate Spider-Man
landscape the Ultimate Universe was
never designed to be this great big huge
grandiose thing like the main Marvel
Universe I mean the main Marvel Universe
was really kind of built by Stan Lee
Jack Kirby Steve ditko a handful of
other writers and artists in the 1960s
and 70s and then it grew to what it is
now where it's just massive in scope and
you have the Avengers and you have you
know caliber and you have Alpha flight
and you have you know the Brotherhood of
evil mutants and the X-Men and so on and
so forth the Ultimate Universe was
designed to be far more contained and
much much smaller in scale and so the
result is that when it came to the
Ultimate Spider-Man stories by uh Brian
Michael Bendis the idea was to basically
keep things relatively small to tell
these small volumes where characters
would appear and then never be seen or
heard from again or else if they were
seen they were just in a containment
cell where they were being held by
Shield or something along those lines
but it was very easy to digest and it
was very very easy to follow and that's
one of the reasons why the Ultimate
Universe was relatively popular but in
the end people still gravitated toward
the characters that they thought of when
they thought of Captain America when
they thought of Thor and so on and so
forth now with regards to Miles Morales
Peter Parker was basically the recipient
of a bite from a spider that contained
the oz formula and again the whole idea
here in the Ultimate Universe was that
Nick Fury I guess Samuel Jackson Nick
figure if you want to call him that Nick
Fury was the original Super Soldier and
when the super soldier serum that was
used on Nick Fury proved to be
successful it resulted in in this great
Gold Rush more or less for everybody to
create their own super soldiers and so
that's where Wolverine came from
Wolverine was the recipient of Canada's
attempt to create a super soldier serum
but along the way they discovered a
mutant Gene that when activated would
give people powers and that was the
origin of the mutant race in the
Ultimate Universe when it came to
Spider-Man he had a guide Norman Osborne
who was basically trying to create a
super soldier serum and he created
something called the oz formula and
where he was going through and testing
it on different spiders one of these
Fighters bit Peter Parker which led him
to become a Spider-Man in The Ultimate
Universe but following the course of his
publication history somewhere around 160
issues or so which this is far shorter
than that I think Miles Morales story is
probably total in like maybe 30 or 40
issues it's not really that long at all
but following the publication history of
Peter Parker he eventually died and the
reason was because Marvel was wanting to
basically make way for a new Spider-Man
and that just made good sense I mean you
had Ultimate Spider-Man Peter Parker and
then you had the main Marvel Universe
Peter Parker why have two versions of
the same character give us a new
Spider-Man and so that's what they did
they killed off Peter Parker and they
had had a had a spider basically bite a
new kid by the name of Miles Morales who
gained Peter Parker's powers and then a
couple of his own that Peter didn't have
for example Miles Morales can administer
this venom venom shock which is
basically kind of like an electrical
impulse that basically shocks a person
that's touching him or something along
those lines he can make himself
invisible he can camouflage himself that
kind of a thing and so again miles was
very much its own character but the
whole idea here and really where this
Story begins to pick up as we start to
get into uh his uncle Aaron Davis now
the crazy thing about Aaron Davis's
character is that as interesting as he
is there's a lot more to him than meets
the eye it's not as clean cut as him
just being a con man but that's how he
comes off he comes off as a con artist
he comes off as a thief and a cheat but
he's actually a very capable guy and the
way this story unfolds is it's actually
going to be a sort of a battle of
allegiances so to speak for Miles
Morales himself but what is up happening
here is we actually pick up with Aaron
Davis traveling back or at least
intending to meet the tinkerer now the
tinkerer is basically a character who
creates devices I mean really the Tinker
was who we saw in the Spider-Man
Homecoming movie that was working
alongside Michael Keaton the other half
of this is that it also deals with the
introduction of a new version of the
Scorpion and the reason why I say new
version is because of the fact that in
the Peter Parker Ultimate Spider-Man
line of comics and those stories the
Scorpion was introduced but he was
actually introduced as a clone of Peter
Parker the issue with this was that with
Brian Michael bendus writing the story
at the time and wanting to create a new
Spider-Man it also made sense to give
this new Spider-Man Miles Morales his
own villains to face off against and so
what ended up happening is uh the
Scorpion as he appeared in the original
Peter Parker stories in the Ultimate
Universe he was basically defeated he
was revealed to be a clone of Peter
Parker and then he was just never really
seen or heard from again after he was
taken captive by Shield that was really
it this version of Scorpion seems to be
more in line with the Scorpion that we
saw from Spider-Man Homecoming this
scorpion seems to be more grounded in
terms of who he is and what he's about
and that kind of a thing his backstory
Still Remains pretty ambiguous and it
will for a little while but suffice it
to say he's basically in New York
because of the fact that Prowler owes
him cash and that's really about it now
the other half of this is Miles Morales
trying to make his way and trying to
figure out how to be a superhero but the
other thing to focus on here is that
miles is struggling with the exact same
thing that Peter Parker did and that's
one of the cool things about this is
that what Benders and them are basically
saying is that no matter what Universe
we're in for the most part unless the
character is drastically different from
who we're used to he's always going to
struggle with the same thing should he
tell his friends and family who he is
and if he does what are the consequences
of that because remember if you were to
tell his mom for example that he's
Spider-Man she may believe him she may
not believe him but if she has that
knowledge it makes her a target for
somebody else and so she basically can't
spill the beans on something she doesn't
know anything about and if miles never
tells her then nobody has any reason to
go after her they have no reason to
connect the two people now something
else to focus on is that again when
business and them created Miles Morales
they didn't just abandon the concept of
Peter Parker in his entirety I mean he's
dead he doesn't show up and he won't
show up again until Spider-Man but the
idea here was to keep the legacy of
Peter Parker going Genki really just
kind of goes to Miles and says look it's
cool that you're Spider-Man but you
don't really know what you're doing
and Peter Parker is not here to teach
you what you need to know because he's
dead and so you need to be able to learn
what Peter Parker knew from Peter Parker
himself the best way you know how which
is to basically watch movies of Peter
Parker fighting and that's kind of the
cool thing because you know miles gets a
video gets to watch a you know watch
footage of the Ultimate Universe Peter
Parker facing off against Dr Octopus
nothing too significant but his first
real attempt in trying to stand toe-ito
and trying to really become Spider-Man
comes with the arrival of a character by
the name of Omega Red now Omega Red in
the Ultimate Universe was starkly
different from his character in the in
the main Marvel Universe in the main
Marvel Universe Omega Red was the
byproduct of the Russians trying to
duplicate Wolverine that's really all it
was it was the idea that Wolverine had
been taken by The Weapon X Project his
healing Factor had been used in order to
bond his body with adamantium and the
result was that he ended up going
forward as just this adamantium laced
killing machine the Russians try to
duplicate the same process but the
difference here is that the Russians
didn't know the formula for adamantium
and so because of that they ended up
creating a cheap knockoff called
carbonadium now carbonadium is still
pretty durable and it's still pretty
potent in terms of what it's capable of
but naturally this eventually led to a
battle of sorts between Omega Red and
Wolverine with the two of them becoming
mortal enemies in the Ultimate Universe
it was starkly different Omega Red was
basically just a guy who was a mutant he
gained these powers that allowed him to
just kind of expand these organic
tendrils from his body he could emit
toxins different things like that but he
wasn't nearly as capable as his main
Marvel counterpart but the reason why
this is important is because of the fact
that for Miles Morales going against
somebody like Omega Red is going against
someone he's never experienced before
and so it's really him kind of on the
edge of his seat using his powers as
best he can trying to become a
legitimate hero because with trying to
dodge these tendrils and so on it
requires him to use basically every
ounce of agility he has as we would
expect he comes out on top but the idea
of Aaron Davis being rolled in as part
of Miles Morales Spider-Man's story
comes when again Aaron Davis basically
encounters the tinkerer and it's the
idea that the tinkerer you know when
Aaron Davis is looking at this newspaper
about a new Spider-Man and so on and so
forth fourth the tanker basically gives
Aaron Davis the whole backstory of how
Spider-Man became Spider-Man the
original Peter Parker became Spider-Man
of course as we talked about Norman
Osborne created the odds formula so on
and so forth but this also rings a bell
for the prowler because remember in our
video on the origin of Miles Morales he
was bitten by a spider in front of Uncle
Aaron Davis and the result was that
Aaron Davis saw the spider and saw a
number on and so because of that when
you know tinkerer begins to explain all
these things about what Osborne was
doing how he would perform experiments
on these spiders he would number them
and he would catalog them in order to
keep track of what his experiments were
doing and how they were progressing
Aaron Davis comes to the realization
that a numbered spider bit his nephew
and then suddenly there's this new
Spider-Man on the scene two and two
together Miles Morales is Spider-Man and
that's why I say that Tyler Aaron Davis
is actually sharper than people give him
credit for I mean he's smarter than your
average bear I guess but it's kind of a
cool thing because it sets the stage for
this idea of Aaron Davis being brought
in asking for some pretty nefarious
things and that's really the first thing
that he does I mean as soon as he
realizes that miles is Spider-Man he
goes to him and says hey man like we
should work together like we can put our
efforts together and we can really
achieve something great now remember
miles was informed by his father that
his uncle Aaron was a was a con artist
and a crook and served time in jail
miles father was heading down the same
path and so Miles father basically
warned him hey look do not get in the
mix with your uncle Aaron the other half
of this is that Miles father I wouldn't
go as far as to say is a very cautious
man so much as he's trying to ensure his
son stays safe but he's also a little
overprotective and this is where the
whole element of loyalties begins to
come into play because with Miles
Morales he's kind of stuck in two
different situations the first is that
he believes in his father I mean this is
his dad you know he follows his father
as best he can but it almost feels like
his father is trying to shelter him from
the world's experiences and life in and
of itself people growing and becoming
something better than they are is all
about experiences doing something stupid
and learning from that experience at the
same time it's his uncle Aaron Davis and
he knows that he's a crook but if he
wants to go out and experience life
there's a lot of different ways to do
that but family is family blood is blood
and so again that's one of the
interesting things about this this story
and that's one of the reasons why I've
Loved miles morales's character for so
long is because it's just the inner
struggle between the two of them now
with regards to Aaron Davis having
killed the tinkerer so that nobody would
know about the the possibility of Miles
Morales being Ultimate Spider-Man it
also comes into play with him I guess
re-encountering scorpion again and this
is when we basically learned that
scorpion was owed money by Aaron Davis
that presumably Aaron Davis essentially
cheated him out of cash scorpion comes
back looking for his money now the other
half of this is that we also get some
perspective in terms of what Scorpion's
capable of and what we're actually
informed here is that he's not just some
crazy guy you know who is a mob boss out
of Mexico instead he does have some
abilities and one of the most notable is
a highly resistant skin Aaron Davis
ultimately just ends up fleeing for his
life when he begins to realize just how
capable scorpion is and then he's not
really a pushover now of course this
leads to exactly what we would expect it
to in the sense that Aaron Davis
essentially flees to his nephew Miles
Morales and this is probably one of the
best elements of the story and the
reason for this is because Aaron Davis
approaching his nephew is done from ill
intent like it's him showing up and
essentially having this ulterior motive
there's a guy trying to kill me I want
to try to take him out so on and so
forth but he doesn't say that he doesn't
go to Miles Morales and say hey man I
did something really bad I screwed a guy
over in Mexico and he got here to New
York and he's trying to kill me you got
to help me take this guy out that's not
what he says instead what he does is he
pawns it off on the idea of being a
tutor of sorts and that's kind of the
cool thing because Aaron Davis uses you
know basically the abilities of a suit
combined with his own experiences to
engage miles in hand-to-hand combat and
this is why I say sometimes despite the
fact that there can be nefarious
purposes here at the end of the day uh
there is still something to be learned
and so while Aaron Davis is trying to
manipulate his own nephew Aaron Davis is
teaching miles how to become a more
effective fighter because remember miles
doesn't have any martial arts training
he doesn't have military training he has
no kind of training at all he's a kid
who was bitten by a radioactive spider
and then suddenly has all these powers
and so he doesn't know how to fight he
doesn't have any of that kind of
training stuff he's really just flying
by the seat of his pants every step of
the way in every single conflict he gets
into now the other half is to remember
he learns as he goes through and that's
kind of the cool thing is because he's
literally learning to fight while he's
fighting and so that's one of the the
crazy things about his character and his
Evolution but the idea of Aaron Davis is
saying look I'm trying to help you out
here now Aaron is not totally evil like
he's not a total bad guy he's not just
like I don't care whether you live or
die I'm just trying to make sure that
this guy scorpion gets off my back
instead it's really this idea that he's
going to him and he's saying look I
don't want to see you killed and that
really is one of the reasons why Aaron
Davis's character is so intricate and is
so complex is because on one half he's a
thief he's a con artist he's a
manipulator but at the other half that's
family that's his nephew the last
Spider-Man was killed by his own enemies
it'd be a lot easier for Miles Morales
to be killed by different foes because
he doesn't have nearly the experience or
the training that Peter Parker had and
so again it's kind of a cool scenario
now of course ultimately miles is able
to overcome and Davis to the point that
he proves that he's able to hold his own
to a degree and this is where the
conversation begins to unfold is because
Aaron Davis basically says I want to
train you I want to make you a good
fighter I want to turn you into somebody
who can be a legitimate superhero and
this is why it's kind of this idea that
these two characters have conflicting
sides where you know Aaron Davis is just
kind of a small time Crook and a con man
and Miles Morales is trying to be a good
guy at the end of the day they have a
common goal and the common goal is to
take out an even worse bad guy named
Scorpion and so that's the common ground
that the two of them reside on at this
moment it allows the characters to sort
of progress and to grow and so on and so
forth and so where we ultimately have
miles is kind of cruising the internet
and trying to learn about this scorpion
character and we eventually have him
just sort of mulling this entire
situation over and then ultimately
agreeing to side with his uncle Aaron
against the wishes of his parents after
learning that this guy scorpion has
engaged in Acts of racketeering murder
theft violating other human beings this
guy is just a genuinely terrible human
being and so because of that you know
ultimately miles ends up siding with his
with his uncle which again sets the
stage for some pretty cool stuff but
okay uh so we are a couple weeks out
from the release of the PlayStation 5
and Miles Morales Spider-Man uh
Spider-Man Miles Morales I guess is what
they're calling it whatever it is the
Spider-Man 2 game uh and here's the
thing okay I'm actually kind of sad
about this uh myself and where I have
not pre-ordered like we didn't get a
chance to pre-order the PS5 right are
the pre-orders were out like that like
it was it was insane uh so here's the
deal are there any members of the Rob
Corps in Columbus Ohio that can hook up
myself and Mariah with PlayStation fives
right I'll give you like an extra 200
bucks plus the cost of the PlayStation
fives if you can hook us up uh that
would be awesome right that'd be that'd
be super cool if you can send me an
email where all the comics
displaying.com that would be amazing I
don't know if any of you guys can uh
we'll even go as far as Cleveland if we
have to but uh that'd be awesome if you
guys could right so
um it's been a little while since we
covered Miles Morales right we covered
the first two and I think we did it like
three years ago so we're gonna do a
little bit of catch up here for people
who are are really uncertain and who are
kind of lagging behind in the midst of
all this so Miles Morales becoming
Spider-Man came out of what was
basically like cataclysm to a degree
right it was it was basically this great
big huge story arc in in the Ultimate
Universe where that version of
Spider-Man had died right so a little
bit of explanation here the Ultimate
Universe was lost in 2000 and it was the
answer to the question what would it
look like if superheroes existed in the
real world right a more modern depiction
of superheroes as we know them in Marvel
Comics The Ultimate Universe was hugely
popular and it was basically launched
with Ultimate Spider-Man right with
Peter Parker now when Peter Parker died
Spider-Man fans were pissed right they
were so mad because they loved that
version of Spider-Man and as we know as
comic book fans we don't really like it
when things change right we like things
to stay the same forever and ever and
ever because when things are different
it takes us getting used to it again and
we just don't want to have to go through
all that you know we kind of we're old
people right we just get stuck in our
ways and the result of this is that when
Miles Morales initially came onto the
scene there was a lot of hate for the
character of Miles the funny thing is
he's hugely popular now so much so that
like when he's got his own game and two
I've heard nothing but people being
excited about the a new Miles Morales
game right so as with most things in
comics give it time and you may end up
finding that you like it but the the
whole thing behind this is that in the
early days and kind of in the beginning
of this Miles Morales having been bitten
by a spider that gave him radioactive
powers and much the same way that Peter
Parker did was met with a lot of
backlash in the Ultimate Comics Universe
right like in the actual Comics
themselves because Peter Parker had like
just died and then miles you know in
order to honor the memory of Peter went
out and got a Spider-Man suit and then
was like okay uh let's let's be
Spider-Man right he was met by like Nick
Fury he was met by uh Jessica Drew or
whatever you want to call her basically
the Ultimate Universe version of
Spider-Girl Spider Woman and uh and they
were kind of like you can do this right
like you're disrespecting the memory of
Peter but the reality was that Miles
believed that he was honoring the memory
of Peter right like he believed he was
doing the right thing and so ultimately
he ended up getting the blessing of Nick
Fury and then this led to the
introduction of the prowler right and
the prowler was a character who had
already been around and the prowler was
basically uh the the uncle of Miles
Morales uh he was basically Aaron right
and then the idea behind this was that
you ended up having miles basically
allying himself with Aaron out of that
you know as part of Aaron's request now
when miles sort of realized that things
were a little sketchy here that's when
all this kind of started popping off
right but this this really is kind of
like when two of them first start
teaming up we as the reader knew that
Aaron was a bad guy right like we knew
he was basically a villain he was one of
the most Wanted men in the United States
and in fact he was wanted by Interpol
and the FBI right like it was a huge
deal again it's probably one of the best
thieves if not the best thief in the
entirety of the Ultimate Universe he was
kind of a big deal now with him and
Miles teaming up for the first time this
involves them going after a guy by the
name of Scorpion a Marvel in the
Ultimate Universe you had two versions
of the Scorpion character and you're
probably familiar with him from like
maybe Spider-Man the Animated Series
back in the 90s or comic books or
whatever the case is but the Scorpion
that you initially saw in Ultimate
Comics was part of the Ultimate Universe
line of the clone saga right like
cloning Peter Parker that's where you
know the Jessica character came from and
so on but the Scorpion was a clone of
Peter Parker right so that was kind of
like that version that we saw I wouldn't
go as far as to say he was hugely
popular I honest honestly didn't really
enjoy the whole concept but the thing
about this is that this version of
Scorpion that we see here is the guy
who's actually named Maximus gargan
right so his name is almost identical to
the one from the main Marvel Universe
Max gargan the difference here is that
unlike Matt gargan and the main Marvel
Universe who's just a guy who's a
criminal uh and then in the Ultimate
Universe Maximus gargan was basically a
Mexican crime Lord It's essentially what
he was he was like a Mexican drug
kingpin but he was working for Prowler
and so essentially you had this kind of
exchange it was supposed to go on
between the two of them but basically
Maximus gargan ended up turning on the
prowler it led into a great big huge
fight Prowler basically got out of there
and then Maximus has come here to New
York City in order to make himself a
Kingpin and because of the fact that he
was able to overcome Prowler before the
indication is he can do it again right
so he's not too worried about the
prowler's character but that's why
they're here is because Aaron is trying
to get rid of Maximus or trying to get
rid of Scorpion because Scorpion's
encroaching on his Turf the the idea
that he's pitching to Miles Morales is
he's a bad guy right so we gotta get rid
of bad guys so he's essentially using
miles desire to be a hero in order to
effectively turn miles into his own
enforcer is really kind of what's
Happening Here but scorpion showing up
here and just being like okay so like
you know this is my this this is my spot
now right like I'm taking over this like
I was a guy who operated in Mexico
that's true but like now I want to swim
with the bigger fish right and so I'm
taking the entirety of New York over I'm
going to become its new Kingpin the the
funny thing about this is that he's
immediately met by Aaron right he's
immediately met by the prowler and in
turn the prowler's like okay so like you
gotta go
right you gotta you gotta go now the
response of of scorpion is like you
still owe me payment right like you
still owe me for our last deal that went
down technically that's true that that
when that deal initially went down that
Aaron was the one who refused to love to
his under the bargain now he did so
under the auspices that scorpion tried
to double cross him right and saying
like you forfeited your share of this
whole thing when you tried to double
cross me but technically a deal is a
deal and so the result of this is that
you know Scorpion's here to kind of call
in his in and take out the prowler if he
can and then take over New York himself
now of course this leads to Spider-Man
jumping in now there are questions that
you're most likely asking here right
where are characters like Daredevil or
like Luke Cage or Heroes for hire or any
of the number of ground level heroes
that we see in New York that could
easily respond to a threat like this the
reality of the Ultimate Universe guys is
that it was designed to be a far more
stripped down version of the main Marvel
Universe the main Marvel Universe just
to give you perspective had like
thousands of mutants who had appeared
over the course of Marvel's publication
history and those are the ones that they
focus on for any real measure of time
when you take into account the one-offs
the ones who appeared for like a single
story then you're starting to get into
the hundreds of thousands right that
were just you know so many different
mutants that had appeared and so you
take that and you expand it to like the
almost never-ending roster of Avengers
you add in things like the midnight Suns
right you add in like you know Doctor
Strange's Black Ops Defenders team from
like the 1990s right They carried out
like all these secret missions and
things like that it was super cool it
was an awesome concept it was terribly
executed but it was an awesome concept
but you take all these things into
throwing it in and what you end up in
the main Marvel Universe you end up with
this just hugely expansive landscape of
Heroes and it's insanely difficult to
keep up with it all the Ultimate
Universe wanted to correct that right so
you have like the ultimates you've got
the Fantastic Four you've got the X-Men
you got Spider-Man and that's basically
it right you see other characters kind
of pop in and out but you weren't really
seeing like Ultimate Comics blade right
you weren't really seeing that you
weren't really seeing like Ultimate
Comics werewolf by night where you're
not really seeing any of that stuff
right any of like these characters that
would have been interesting to see
instead it was designed to be super
closed down I would say that overall in
terms of individual Publications right
individual comic book lines I think you
may be capped out at 20 Comics over the
course of the ultimate universe's
lifespan and I'd say that's probably
about it if that right it was very very
very very small seeing other characters
would happen in other characters Comics
things like that right so just just one
of the you know kind of an answer to
that question you know why don't we see
a lot more going on here uh because it's
not designed to be overly huge right
it's one of the great things about the
Ultimate Universe but of course this is
when things pop off
basically you know everybody pulls guns
guns blazing shots fire and everything's
going all to pieces now this is when we
kind of get reminded a little bit of the
of the Scorpion's Powers right and make
sure you guys check down in the
description just kind of a reminder make
sure you check down in the description
you'll find uh Ultimate Spider-Man uh
really the first two videos that we did
volumes one and two you'll find that
down there so you can get caught up and
you won't feel like you're just kind of
flying in out of nowhere but uh but the
idea behind scorpion is that he has
enhanced durability and enhanced
strength now he's not completely
invulnerable and he doesn't have like
super human strength right where he's
like equal to the Incredible Hulk and
strength or anything like that he's just
kind of got enhanced abilities but
they're enough to where he can easily
hold his own against like you know being
shot at or being stabbed or something
along those lines right so he doesn't
really have Luke Cage's skin but
something reasonably close to it the
other part of this is that given his
enhanced abilities he also is able to go
toe-to-toe with Miles Morales but the
reason why this happens is because miles
is still learning about his powers right
he's still learning what he's capable of
now a lot of miles ability to expand
Beyond his existing Horizons will
actually come in the first Spider-Man's
toy which we will cover that's basically
it was it was really cool it was when
Bendis basically told all the Miles
Morales haters to shut up when they were
like he he he's not really Spiderman bit
is literally wrote a story where Peter
Parker from The main Marvel Universe and
Miles Morales from the Ultimate Universe
and and Peter Parker's like who cares
what the world says uh I think you're a
great Spider-Man go forward right and
it's basically business saying hey I
know you guys some of you guys out there
don't like Miles Morales tough luck and
then just like continuing to write the
story it was amazing it was a hilarious
this response to the haters but the the
funny thing about this is that miles is
learning his powers and so when it comes
to somebody like Peter but if we look at
like even the Ultimate Universe Comics
version of Spider-Man Peter Parker or
you look at the main Marvel Universe
version of Spider-Man Peter Parker the
important thing is that in the early
days he had his learning he had his
process where he learned his powers But
as time went on it started to become
second nature to where he could just
react and instinctively know what he
needs to do you know that's one of the
things that kind of came out of dance
slots run is when he was talking about
why Spider-Man would crack jokes all the
time because where you kind of looked at
it and saw Spider-Man is almost kind of
a nonsensical character you know when he
was engaging in in fights and didn't
really seem to be taking it seriously
the reason why he would crack jokes is
because he wanted to make the villains
think he wasn't taking them seriously
and that in turn would piss them off and
the angrier they got the less focused
they became and the easier it would be
for Peter Parker to take them out that's
one of the things that he kind of
learned over the course of his time as
Spider-Man with Miles Morales it'll be
much the same way that as we cover these
Comics you'll quite literally see miles
become better at being Spider-Man but in
these early Comics here in this third
volume of his original run he doesn't
really know what he's doing he doesn't
really have any official training and
that's really what he was told by Nick
Fury when Nick Fury sanctioned him as
being Spider-Man he's like you're on
your own to figure out how to be a
superhero we're not going to train you
right we're not going to give you like
official training at least not at the
moment we're not going to do any of that
right like you just got to become the
best version of Spider-Man that you can
on your own and if you really are meant
to be a great Spider-Man then you will
become one if not then you'll probably
suck and you'll probably end up getting
killed best of luck and that was
basically it
it was kind of a dick move but you know
ultimately one of the things that Miles
ends up doing is underestimating uh
scorpion right in the sense that he's
able to overcome him for a minute and
where Aaron wants to get his revenge on
on Scorpion the responsive miles is no
it's one thing to stop a criminal it's
another to go out of your way and try to
kill the guy right like that's not going
to do anybody any good and and
ultimately miles ends up intending to
kind of Walk Away Now scorpion wakes up
scorpion attacks miles goes invisible he
attacks scorpion again and then when
miles turns us back scorpion gets away
and so it's one of these things where
he's constantly underestimating the
villains that he faces off against but
that's because he simply hasn't learned
that you have to make sure that they're
knocked out right like you know that's
that's one of the things that Peter kind
of learned right as time went on that
like as he would face off against
different villains he would realize just
because they look like they're knocked
out doesn't mean they are like you just
gotta you gotta Pummel them a few extra
times when you gotta so you'll smack him
around a little bit more than you
normally would and then you know then
they'll be knocked out and that'll
that'll basically be it you know you
gotta slap him around a bit is is kind
of what what Peter Parker would do but
of course this leads to to of course you
know uh Miles Morales tracking down uh
tracking down scorpion going to attack
him again and then using his uh his
Venom blast right to essentially
incapacitate him this kind of Venom
shock uh ability that he has to
incapacitate uh scorpion and then
handing scorpion over to the cops now
the response to the police officers is
to initially try to arrest Miles Morales
and that is the way his Comics were
early in the early days right and it
wasn't really like a racial thing it
wasn't like he's wearing a black
Spider-Man costume obviously he's black
get him it wasn't necessarily like that
it was this idea that they didn't know
him like when Peter Parker first showed
up on the scene in a lot of ways it was
kind of a welcoming thing now a lot of
that was because of the fact that it was
Spider-Man right and nobody wants to
really read comics with a world hates
Spider-Man and then two uh because it
was kind of the launch of the Ultimate
Universe right so it was designed to be
kind of a celebratory run you know this
this kind of celebratory every inaugural
run and Peter now he did run into a
whole bunch of problems and there were
times when Society was kind of like you
know but nonetheless you know with Miles
Morales in a lot of ways the the writing
the how the cops were depicted here is
designed to kind of depict the naysayers
right in the sense that he's not
Spider-Man we don't really know what's
going on here but get rid of him you
know he's not legit uh and so as a
result of that of course he makes
himself invisible and ends up taking off
right ends up you know kind of going
back to where Aaron and them were
looking to find Aaron and Aaron
basically disappeared now the next day
you end up getting miles meeting up with
Genki right meeting up with Yankee Lee
the two of them kind of talking you know
and and he's like dude you busted like
Maximus right you busted uh he busted
the Scorpion like he's this this year's
thing and then that's when he starts
talking to uh to his uncle Aaron and his
uncle Aaron's like he's like where'd you
go he's like I want to go get some rest
are you okay and you know it's like okay
like we're just getting started right
like we're gonna get back to this again
and and Miles initial idea is no like I
don't want to be involved in this right
and that's when Aaron kind of breaks out
that that blackmail card in the sense of
like I wanted like then maybe I should
hit up your dad maybe I should tell your
dad what's going on on now that's a
little bit of backstory that we haven't
really explained yet the idea was that
Aaron of course has kind of always been
a criminal his whole life uh it started
out with him just kind of getting into
Mischief when he was younger and then
graduating into you know more more
intense and and uh more not really
violent uh but more serious crimes the
father of miles was involved in that to
a degree but eventually went his own
separate way right he kind of went you
know basically went on the right path
kind of corrected himself and got
himself into a better place the result
of this is that uh the father of miles
does not like Aaron and he does not want
Aaron to have any involvement in Miles
life and he's made that clear to miles
right like do not spend time with your
uncle he's a bad guy right like he's a
criminal like if you follow him like he
will get you into trouble he doesn't
care about anybody he doesn't care about
anything if he can if he leads you to
believe that he cares about you it's
because he's duping you right like he's
using you for his own ends and so that's
one of the things that kind of went on
here is that Miles knew he wasn't really
supposed to be spending time with Aaron
but he has been anyway the other part of
this is that Miles parents don't know
anything about his powers right they
don't know that he's Spider-Man and so
he's kind of trying to keep this secret
from them now it's one of these things
where Aaron knows this and then uses it
against him and says well I mean we can
we can go in there right now right when
miles meets him later on he's like we
can go in there right now and I can just
tell them everything that's going on
Miles response is no fine like I'll meet
with you the same place as last time and
so when the two of them end up meeting
up together miles shows up and says this
is not gonna happen you're like I'll
tell my parents if I need to but here's
what's gonna go on you're gonna leave
town right like you are really a bad
person you're every bit as bad as my dad
said you were right like you really
don't care about anybody but yourself
like you don't come near me you don't
come near my parents right now this was
important for Miles this was a hugely
important moment for Miles Morales and
the reason why is because for his
character the way he was originally
written he wasn't necessarily A people
pleaser but he had this desire to
connect with his uncle Aaron and the
fact that he was able to connect to a
degree uh even when he was younger and
he spent time with him knowing that he
wasn't necessarily supposed to you know
in this moment right now spending time
with his uncle Aaron and trying to to
get to you know get to know him on a
more personal level is compounded and
made Difficult by the fact that Aaron
really is a bad guy and so coming to him
with Miles Morales being largely a
character who lacked a lot of confidence
in himself right he lacked confidence in
himself what he was capable of and what
he could achieve two in turn come along
and to go against somebody somebody like
the prowler who despite not having the
powers of Spider-Man is wildly capable
of going toe-to-toe with one uh is you
know he's basically saying like you're
gonna leave here right like You're Gonna
Leave This Town you're never gonna talk
to me or my parents again you know and
and it's one of these things where where
prowler's like fine like if you want to
play with the big boys then you gotta be
ready and then he in turn attacks Miles
Morales and this is not easy fight for
Miles right using a combination of all
of his gadgetry his Sonics all those
things at his disposal he's able to kind
of get the get the upper hand on miles
but one of the important things here is
that Miles starts to gain more
confidence in his abilities and begins
to use his powers in the way that he's
supposed to right making himself
invisible using you know using a sneak
attack using subtlety different things
like that and that's one of the
important things to understand man is
that when it comes to someone like miles
what he lacks an experience he makes up
for in powers that Peter Parker simply
just didn't have Peter Parker did not
have a Venom blast he could not make
himself invisible right and so you know
with with Miles the fact that he's still
learning how to fight this actually
bends itself to his favor right instead
of being something that can just enhance
his existing abilities it can help him
compensate for his lack of experience
right making himself invisible and then
coming back around again and so he's
able to to kind of get the upper hand on
Aaron and actually ends up damaging one
of his gloves right one of his power
gloves and when that happens of course
the fight ends up leading down into the
street where basically there's almost
like this massive wrecker or this this
city bus you know kind of topples over
when Aaron ends up blasting it right
with his gloves and that's really when
miles begins to get the bigger picture
that Aaron really doesn't care about
anybody but himself that he really is a
tried and true villain and this is also
significant because one of the biggest
issues that Miles had is he had this
desire to inherently see the good in
everybody and while that's not
necessarily A Bad Thing That kind of
naivety can really really cause you
problems later on down the line right
the belief that people are inherently
good if they end up doing bad things
just because they were in a rough spot
but they want to become good people that
can cost lives and that's what miles is
learning here that Aaron isn't a guy who
was just down on his luck and ended up
in a bad spot and there's a way to reach
him and turn him back into a good guy
he's just a bad person and the fact that
he's willing to like endanger the lives
of a busload of people in order to to to
get the upper hand in a fight against
Miles Morales really shows the kind of
person that he is and so at that point
Miles Morales starts Cutting Loose right
he starts letting loose and it's just
like fun like like if that's how we're
gonna fight then let's fight this is
gonna be a knock down drag out fight he
uses his Venom blast starts you know
starts literally hitting Aaron from
every direction and getting the upper
hand the problem with this is that in a
split second Aaron gets the upper hand
on on Miles and goes to attack him and
seemingly does it with the intention of
killing him the problem with this is the
previous attack by Miles that damaged
his glove ends up coming home to roost
when the whole thing explodes right it's
like a bomb going off and when that
happens it kills Aaron right it looks it
kills Aaron and so it's just kind of
like the last little word that Miles
gets here from Aaron is like look at
that right you're just like me you don't
care who you kill as long as you come
out on top it's just this crushing
response to Miles effectively getting
his uncle killed or seemingly getting
his uncle killed what's going on guys
this is Rob and we are here with
Ultimate Spider-Man venomor I.E the
story where Miles Morales fights Venom
and the ending of the story is amazing
so I'm really excited to see how you
guys respond to this but what this does
is this initially opens up with Miles
Morales and his family enjoying dinner
together but when there's a knock on the
door and Jefferson Davis the father of
Miles answers it reporters come barging
in and then asking him whether or not
he's like the new Spider-Man is a true
he overpowered Hydra all that kind of
stuff now the reason why they're asking
Jefferson Davis these questions is
twofold the first has to do with the
reporter named Betty Brandt and the
second has to do with Jefferson Davis
own history so focusing on Betty brand
here for a second the way this played
out is Betty Brant being a reporter
working at The Daily Bugle she had
uncovered what she believed to be the
true identity of the current Spider-Man
running around that basically replaced
Peter Parker after Peter died in the
Ultimate Universe and she believed that
person to be Jefferson Davis now a lot
of that was just based on Jefferson's
own history along with her just kind of
putting pieces together and maybe
cooking the books a little bit and the
reason why I say that is because
Jefferson is incredibly accomplished in
the sense that there was one point where
he was captured by Hydra he overpowered
them and then executed a whole bunch of
Hydra soldiers there was a point where
he became a spy for shield working for
Nick Fury and spied on a guy named Turk
who was a criminal warlord so the guys
got the kind of chops that you would
expect from a person who would be a
Spider-Man but the fact that Miles lives
in the same home as Jefferson gave Betty
Brandt the belief that Jefferson was
Spider-Man because while miles is
running out and doing all the Spider-Man
stuff his base of operations is in that
general area so again it was really more
Betty Brant trying to put the pieces
together now of course Jefferson Davis
gets eight kinds of pissed off when
reporters barge into his house and start
asking him questions and so once he
forces all of them out he ends up
leaving right he ends up going for a
walk and in that moment he's immediately
set upon by the Venom symbiote who's
been hunting for Spider-Man now here's
one of the things we need to explain
here the Venom symbiote in the Ultimate
Universe is not the same as the Venom
symbiote in the main Marvel Universe in
Earth 616 in Marvel Comics the main
Marvel Universe the Venom symbiote is an
alien that was created by a guy called
null in the Ultimate Universe the Venom
symbiote is actually a biosuit it was an
attempt to create a kind of healing suit
that could basically heal anybody from
virtually any injuries they sustain the
grand idea was to use it for military
applications bonded to soldiers send
them into the field that kind of a thing
but as time progressed and when you had
the original War of the Symbiote with
Eddie Brock Jr being the original host
for Venom that initially was believed
the Venom Suit was destroyed now little
bits of the Venom Suit survived and it's
been taken by different people over the
years in this instance the version of
Venom that we see here is actually owned
and operated by roxon Industries but
we'll talk about them here in a second
the important takeaway from this is that
when the Venom Suit shows up of course
Miles Morales responds exactly the way
that you would expect him to now one of
the things that I want to specify here
is that miles is still figuring out how
to be Spider-Man and the reason why this
matters is because with Venom going
after Jefferson and Miles responding if
this was Peter Parker he would have
lured Venom to a location where there
were no bystanders there were no
Innocents instead miles is fighting out
of desperation the desire to keep his
father safe and to keep different
civilians around here protected but that
lack of experience comes to bear in the
sense that he's almost immediately
overwhelmed by Venom and the fight is
amazing I'm he Abdul Venom absolutely
pummels this guy when it comes to
Spider-Man facing off against villain's
wreck Peter Parker or really any
Spider-Man just kind of jokes and does
all kinds of little cracky things and so
on and so forth but through it all Peter
very rarely ever loses the upper hand
right Miles Morales ain't that way and
so while miles is getting thrown around
like a rag doll I mean just getting
absolutely crushed by Venom that in turn
like these Cops show up and start
opening fire so then Venom turns his
attention to the cops and starts to help
them finish with all of their living now
of course miles jumps in Miles jumps in
and starts attacking the Venom symbiote
yet again now one of the things that I
will give miles here but I gotta give
miles credit for this this kid's
fighting with every ounce of strength
that he has and he's doing his best
right I don't mean to discredit him and
be like miles you are a trash Spider-Man
he's doing his best now one of the
things that I also want to point out
here is that miles is aware of Venom to
a degree and it's only because of the
fact that he saw YouTube videos where
Spider-Man where Peter Parker Spider-Man
had fought Venom so that's the only
reason why he's even aware of the idea
of like Venom's weaknesses but what he
ends up doing is using his Venom blast
on Venom and when that happens literally
the Venom to me it just kind of succumbs
to it and just sort of explodes it's not
really like blowing up all over the
place but it kind of scrambles the
nature of the Symbiote and ends up
sending the Symbiote running and so
following that Jefferson Davis is taken
to the hospital now what follows next is
morally questionable at best and just
downright diabolical at worst but we'll
talk about that here in a second what we
actually end up doing here is Miles gets
information because one of the things to
remember is that Miles has never
actually faced off against Venom and he
doesn't even know why Venom's coming
after him in the first place or why he
even went after Jefferson Davis and so
what you end up having is Miles and his
friend Genki meeting with Gwen Stacy and
Mary Jane Watson now these two are
incredibly important in relation to this
part of the story and the reason why is
because Gwen Stacy was caught up in the
original War of the Symbiotes and when I
say that I mean she was basically killed
by the original Eddie Brock Jr Venom
right the original host for the Venom
symbia and she was in fact absorbed into
it which was kind of a crazy thing
because as this conversation unfolds
what they say here is that venom has a
deep-rooted DNA genetic connection to
the Parker block bloodline now the
reason for this is because of the fact
that the Venom symbiote was in one part
created by Peter Parker's dad in The
Ultimate Universe he was one half of the
creation team that led to Venom coming
into existence and so what she says is
it was originally created from Peter's
father's DNA and it had literally
stalked and hunted Peter once he or
Venom or in whatever you want to call it
realized who Peter was now with Peter
gone it may just be looking for you
because like him you became Spider-Man
so whatever was special about Peter
Parker genetically you might have the
same thing and so the reason why this
matters is that with like Betty Brent
dead and Peter Parker dead no one really
knows why the Venom symbiote is doing
what it's doing right now it feeds on
energy and life force so the best
estimation we can get is that it's just
kind of driven by a desire to absorb
whoever Spider-Man is and then expand
its own abilities based on the powers of
that Spider-Man but having said that
when I mentioned that what happened next
was just morally questionable at best in
just diabolical at worst the Venom
symbiote breaks into a hospital it
literally attacks a hospital who does
that man right you guys remember that
scene from The Punisher when Frank
Castle rolled into the hospital and was
just shooting the place up in the TV
show it's like that man it's just some
villainous stuff right I mean you
literally have people on Gurney's the
Symbiotes attacking damn right folks who
are just like in the middle of surgery
or bleeding out right or like paralyzed
or something like that I mean it's a
slaughterhouse man and it keeps talking
about how like give me Spider-Man and I
will let all of you leave with your
lives right I will let all of you guys
survive it's diabolical dude it's pretty
messed up
but here's the thing right here's the
thing so once miles shows up here right
miles has learned from his fight with
the Venom Symbian and that's one of the
things that made miles story so cool is
because as the reader much like what we
saw with Ultimate Spider-Man Peter
Parker you saw him learn how to become
Spider-Man as he was operating as
Spider-Man and that's one of the reasons
why as soon as he shows is back up here
he immediately starts using his Venom
blast on Venom but lest we forget while
miles has adapted and learned with his
Venom blast and his first fight with uh
with Venom so has the Symbiote and so
instead of allowing miles to stay in
close proximity to him for any measure
of time he just starts throwing him
around because he realizes that even
with Miles being Spider-Man and having
enhanced speed and reflexes and so on
and so forth the most effective thing he
can do is to shut miles down as fast as
humanly possible to literally overpower
him to hammer him so hard that he's
completely overwhelmed and exhausted
within minutes and that's exactly what
happens I mean this Venom semia comes in
and it's just like round two son ding
ding and like literally takes it to him
man he beats his ass like he owes him
money and then as soon as that happens
he immediately absorbs miles and it's
the smartest move for the Venom Simeon
to do here it's the smartest thing he
could have possibly done now while this
whole thing is watching miles mom is
freaking out right she's literally watch
her son being eaten by like a giant
monster but one of the big moments that
came out of this story right one of the
biggest things that come out of the
story is this is when we learn that
Miles mom knew he was Spider-Man and we
didn't know beforehand not that I'm
aware of right as far as I'm aware
before this moment we never knew that
Miles mom knew that he was Spider-Man
but once she realized that that was the
case she starts begging the Venom
Symbian please let my son go and the
symbias just like your family has caused
me a lot of trouble you have no idea
what I have done to get here and
seemingly he's gonna consume her too but
what miles does is as he's trapped
inside the Venom symbiote he literally
unloads this massive Venom blast and
it's just this really really amazing
moment because when that happens we end
up finding out the current host of the
Venom symbiote is a guy named Marcus now
we'll learn more about him here in a
second because his motivation is really
really cool but the other thing that
ends up happening here and this was a
huge moment when this happened in the
comic is that Rio the mother of miles is
caught in the crossfire with the cops
and she's mortally injured she's
literally killed by the police officers
and everything starts going nuts after
that because what we end up doing is we
switch over to Roxanne Industries now
while reports are coming out right the
news is reporting on everything that's
going on about the whole Venom symbiote
and everything with a guy named Marcus
and so on it is inevitable that Marcus
is going to be traced back to roxon
because Marcus was an employee of
Roxanne and in fact that's what they say
right they like the news says we're
still waiting for official word from
roxon as to what they know about this
man and how this has all come to pass
was Marcus's violent mutation some sort
of experiment or an accident gone wrong
now the reality here is that if Roxanne
doesn't get out in front of this before
things snowball too fast conspiracy
theories and everything will take hold
and so the head of roxon right the man
himself he says you'll inform the media
that the roxon corporation is working
with authorities in all capacities so
that this terrible tragedy can be put
behind us but what we're actually doing
here is making sure that no one can
connect what happened tonight to What's
Happening Here what we are doing is
waiting until this all blows over and
then we will find out exactly what this
Marcus was doing with the Symbiote in
the first place what we're going to do
is wait until no one is watching us and
when I give the word I want to find out
how Spider-Man became Spider-Man and why
we can't figure out how to make a
Spider-Man for ourselves and so that's
the big thing here is because roxon
basically got their hands on a sample of
the Venom symbiote following the defeat
and death of Eddie Brock Jr and so roxon
has been using the Symbiote
experimenting on it and trying to find a
way to create their own version of
Spider-Man now presumably what roxon
would do is they would kill Miles
Morales Spider-Man and replace him with
their own and that version of Spider-Man
would be beholden to rock song but for
Miles himself when he wakes up the next
morning and the reality hits him that
his mom is dead he immediately freaks
out and feeling the same kind of pain
that Peter felt in losing Uncle Ben he
quits right he's like I'm done he gives
up being Spider-Man tears the suit apart
and wants to have nothing to do with it
anymore
okay so we are covering Spider-Man but
here's something that I want to throw
out there real quick right because I
know some people are going to ask the
question Rob didn't you cover this
already what I covered was Spider-Man 2.
uh here's the important thing about this
right Spider-Man is probably one of the
most important Spider-Man stories I'd
say of the last 15 years and the reason
why is because this is the story where
Peter Parker first met Miles Morales
right so um one of the things that we've
talked about here over the course of of
really some of the miles moralist videos
that we've done and a lot of the Peter
Parker videos that we did is we kind of
talked about the nature of the Ultimate
Universe right so if you guys are
familiar with this we just finished the
video yesterday where we talked about
that in the Miles Morales one right so
just kind of bear with me right we'll
probably have some new people to the
channel I know you guys kind of like to
get directly into it but bear with me
for a second while I kind of I kind of
reiterate this uh for for the people who
are new here right who are new to Marvel
Comics um in Marvel you have a great big
huge Multiverse right technically the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is considered
part of the Multiverse that makes up all
of Marvel Comics uh we know that for a
couple different reasons one because it
actually has a numerical designation
among the Marvel Multiverse and two
because there's Comics based on it right
so that kind of brings it closer in line
with being part of the Marvel Multiverse
but where you had Marvel Comics as it
was originally launched in the 1960s but
with the Fantastic Four number one and
so on and so forth that's referred to as
earth616 right also known as the main
Marvel Universe what we got in in the
year 2000 was the creation of the
Ultimate Universe and this was an answer
to the question what would it look like
if at that point in time in the year
2000 superheroes had just basically
popped up right they just kind of
emerged for the very first time uh what
would that what would those superheroes
look like how would they function how
would all that stuff work ah and that's
basically where you got Peter Parker in
the Ultimate Universe now Ultimate
Spider-Man was exceedingly popular right
it was hugely popular because in a lot
of ways it was kind of an indirect
reboot right Marvel didn't really reboot
everything with the main Marvel Universe
Spider-Man they just gave us a new one
and people loved it right people
absolutely loved it but what you saw was
a story where basically Peter Parker
died right Peter Parker Spider-Man was
killed and it might behoove us to go
back and cover that event right cover
cataclysm and the death of of Peter
Parker right it might be who of us to do
that just because you know we're kind of
doing a lot of this stuff because the
new Spider-Man games coming out for the
PlayStation uh but the idea is that when
that version of Peter Parker died uh we
ended up getting Miles Morales in his
place and when Miles Morales first
showed up there was a lot of naysayers
there were a lot of people who were just
kind of like Miles Morales sucks he's
not really Spider-Man he's not really
Peter Parker that kind of a thing
because it kind of came from a couple
different places a lot of fans were
latched on to the idea of Peter Parker
even when they were reading him before
the Ultimate Universe was launched right
so all they really got was just another
alternate reality version of Peter and
they loved it a lot of people grew
attached to Peter Parker Spider-Man in
The Ultimate Universe when that was
their first place to start in Marvel
Comics but by whatever Manner and
whatever means a lot of people just
didn't want to see things change this
story is in a lot of ways kind of Brian
Michael bindis snubbing people who were
naysayers of Miles Morales right uh
people who were just like this this
character's not gonna last or anything
like that it was kind of been just being
like no he will like he's gonna be
around for a long time and that's really
where this comes from and I tell you
that because it's important that you
understand the historical context of
this story as we get into it so you can
understand why this story is considered
to be so important with all that out of
the way let us jump to the main story
itself uh and so what we end up getting
here is picking up in the main Marvel
universe or 616 with Peter Parker
Spider-Man and as Peter Parker just kind
of doing the stuff that Peter Parker
does right like swinging around coming
across some criminals some guys who are
doing some things are not supposed to do
but here's the funny thing about this
because of the fact that this story was
written as a way to kind of tie into or
kind of bring together the Ultimate
Universe and the main Marvel Universe
this story was written in such a way to
where it was designed to treat people as
if they're aware of who Spider-Man is
but they don't really know much about
him right they don't really know a whole
lot about the character right so it's
kind of reiterating the nature of Peter
Parker and that's one of the things that
you see in Marvel Comics there are
certain characters out there who people
know who they are right people know who
Iron Man is now people know who
Spider-Man is people know who Wolverine
is but knowing of knowing who the
character is and understanding the
history and the context of the character
are two distinctly different things
you know so a lot of people know who
Iron Man is but I doubt they really know
anything about the Mandarin or I doubt
they know about stories like demon in a
bottle and why it's so important uh what
is it the five nightmares run by Matt
fraction different things like that
right Arnold Stark Kieran gillen's run a
lot of people probably aren't really
familiar with that so uh the idea is
that we're just kind of giving Peter
Parker in terms of how Peter Parker
operates which is to say kind of amusing
to himself about how much he loves New
York City and the fact that New York
City is kind of like a thinking
breathing entity right that there are so
many facets to this city you've got
people who have their nose to the ground
and they're just grinding day in and day
out just trying to make it by you've got
people who are just super high up in
their Ivory Ivory Towers you know the
Tony Starks the Reed Richards who don't
really have to worry about small time
things right but you kind of have
everybody who falls in between and
there's just so many different varying
types of people in the city of New York
that is just so unique in that way what
it also has are criminals
[Laughter]
criminals in New York City and
Spider-Man goes to visit some and he he
basically Wallops them one or two times
shows him what for and then of course
you know ends up pulling over the
vehicle you know which was their getaway
car and as soon as he's there he's met
by the arrival of the cops right and the
cops are just like take off your mask
show us your face you know that kind of
a thing now the truth about this is I
was never really part and parcel to this
kind of depiction of Spider-Man of Peter
Parker and the reason why is because you
have had stories over the years where
jajon and Jameson and The Daily Bugle
have kind of managed to sort of turn you
know the the idea of Spider-Man into
something where he can't really be
trusted he's a menace but the the long
and short of it is that over the years
Spider-Man was largely trusted by
Society right you know your friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man he was the good
guy right he was largely trusted in that
way there have been times where it's
waxed and waned but in this instance I
kind of feel like it should have been
one of those things where it's like
thick Spider-Man you know and then
that's that's kind of it right now the
fact that the cops show up here and he's
behind the behind the wheel of a getaway
car might give him a little reason to be
sus right but I don't know why I say
that all the time Mariah started saying
suss and now I say it all the time right
like sus it's a weird word but anyway uh
once he takes off and he kind of you
know goes and does his thing he ends up
finding this building you know this kind
of uh this office building basically
where the the roof has been shattered
right the glass has been shattered and
he's kind of like that's a little weird
now of course he ends up being drawn to
that location because of a giant bright
light almost kind of an explosion of
sorts and of course once he gets there
like the whole place kind of seems to be
tarnished right and there's just this
white light or this bright light
emanating from it all now as he gets in
there and as he starts investigating his
initial thought is this energy source is
a little weird now this story was
released about a year after Spider-Man
big time and for those of you guys who
aren't really familiar if you ever
wanted to get into Spider-Man I always
suggest people start with big time we
have that that whole series covered on
my channel and big time was the start of
Dan's slots run you had Spider-Man and
you had Mary Jane who were like married
and all that kind of stuff and then you
got one more day then you got brand new
day where Marvel basically nullified it
all uh because that was just so poorly
received big time was kind of Marvel's
huge shift with Peter Parker right
focusing on like an all-new age for
Peter Parker Spider-Man uh but that's
kind of a good place to start right
because dance slots run begins with that
and runs all the way up through Secret
Wars and after Secret Wars into clone
conspiracy right so it's a it's like a
10 almost 15 year long run of Spider-Man
it's very very lengthy but I think it's
also incredibly good I think it's an
amazing run on Spider-Man but the whole
idea behind this is that uh that that
this takes place about a year after that
now the reason why I mentioned that is
because I'm not entirely partial partial
to how this is handled by bendus right
Bendis is notorious for writing a
character and then pretending like
nothing anybody did ever happened right
and it's just like the only things that
matter with this character is what I'm
doing here and ignoring continuity in
its entirety now whether it's kind of
business is always that way I'm not 100
sure I wasn't really reading vendus back
when he was part of uh of event
Publications with Jimmy palmiotti and
Joe Casada I wasn't really reading him
back then I only really got familiar
with Brian Michael bindis once he
actually came into main Marvel itself
and was writing like new Avengers right
uh and New Avengers was a wholly new
thing so he could kind of get away with
that uh it's something that I think
maybe a result of is like his huge
amount of popularity and it's kind of
like I'm bendus I can do whatever in the
heck I want I don't know if that's
really the case case or not but the
reason why that matters is because
during Spider-Man Big Time Peter
Parker's intelligence had always kind of
been downplayed by Marvel Comics right
they never really kind of elevated Peter
Parker to being on par with like Reed
Richards or Tony Stark you always kind
of knew he was but they never really did
any of that form instead what you end up
getting here is Peter Parker kind of
looking at this and just be like man
this is weird he's like it's not it's
not you know anything alien in nature uh
maybe I should get a hold of like Tony
Stark or read witchers or something like
that during big time one of the big
things that Dan slot did was focus on
the intelligence of Peter Parker and in
being like Peter Parker is actually
pretty daggone smart and he doesn't
always need Reid Richards or Tony Stark
to solve a problem on his own that was
kind of solidified in a story where
there was like a bomb that was gonna go
off and nobody else could defuse it and
Peter Parker was the one who did right
so it was kind of elevating his
intelligence up and basically telling
the reader base hey Peter Parker's not
as dumb as he's being made out to be you
know he's not just a Spider-Man right
he's a super intelligent guy let's start
treating him that way so not entirely
partial on how this works but as he
starts navigating this room he starts to
realize all this stuff belongs to Mr
stereo but all these things belong to
him and that's what Mysterio tries to
sneak up behind Peter and attack him and
of course Peter Parker Spider Sense goes
off and he basically ends up you know
kind of kind of being aware that he's
about to be attacked and manages to
dodge out of the way now with Mysterio
and one thing that a lot of you guys are
probably aware of after having seen
Spider-Man far from home Mysterio is a
legitimate credible threat to Peter
Parker right he's probably one of Peter
Parker's most dangerous villains his
ability to cast Illusions to basically
trick Peter Parker and his Spider Sense
it can be pretty difficult to overcome
Mysterio and that's one of the reasons
why you have you know Peter Parker kind
of saying here like I've got to get this
guy down as fast as I can because this
guy is a real and serious threat the
other part of this is that Mysterio
keeps rambling on about how like Peter
Parker's ruining things and he's kind of
destroying things and and so on and so
forth and then he goes as far as to say
like you have no idea what you're
dealing with right you have no idea what
I'm capable of uh I missed out when you
died the first time I'm not going to
miss out this time right so right off
the bat RQ is that this is some kind of
ability for from Mysterio to actually
look through into the Ultimate Universe
where that version of Peter Parker died
and Mysterio wants to be in that
universe or Peter Parker doesn't exist
right his main Nemesis the person that
always foiled his plans he's just trying
to find a way to escape and so what you
end up getting here is is Peter just
kind of looking at this and saying like
like what is this thing right is this
some kind of a power generator or
whatever this is it's weird that this is
here but like I can call people they can
basically break this down and take this
thing apart so we don't really have to
worry about it right while Peter Parker
doesn't really know what's going on with
this device he knows enough about
Mysterio to know it's probably not a
good thing right like when super
villains start doing weird things you
don't understand you can usually just
assume it's bad and you're not usually
wrong in doing that
it's a good rule of thumb to have but of
course in his desperation Mysterio ends
up grabbing uh grabbing a handgun and
firing it off and then missing Peter
Parker and hitting his device and when
that happens he's yanked through right
Peter is seemingly yanked through into
basically the Ultimate Universe and this
is the first time and one of the reasons
why this is so big this is the very very
first time in the history of Marvel
Comics that a character from the main
Marvel Universe crossed over into the
Ultimate Universe right this was a huge
deal now the Ultimate Universe it exists
now in Marvel Comics but it's nowhere
near as a big deal as it was back in
like the early to mid 2000s right at
around the time and even really in the
early 2010s when this story was written
uh this is when the Ultimate Universe
was really kind of at its prime
depending on you know what you were
reading there was a lot of fall off
after the death of Peter Parker you know
we can't really you know that's just an
absolute thing we can't really argue
that point but the death of Peter Parker
in the Ultimate Universe actually made
headlong trying to make national news
headlines and so because that there was
a lot of interest in the Ultimate
Universe and so it was really a great
time to capitalize on that right to kind
of give us this story but this is a big
deal when this first happened and so as
Peter Parker there he's like okay this
is weird like it's suddenly daytime uh I
don't know what that great big huge
building is over there that's the
triskelion that great big huge Tower
looking thing off in the water uh you
guys probably recognize the triskelian
from uh Captain America the Winter
Soldier that's where this comes from
that's why we say the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is a combination of the
Ultimate Universe uh the main Marvel
universe and Earth 98 where the heroes
age in real time uh it's kind of a
combination of those three things but he
ends up traveling back to the building
where uh where where you had you know
the whole
um you know mysterious base of
operations and everything popping off
and uh and he basically ends up breaking
into the place only to find out that
it's occupied with some girl in a towel
and he's like my bad
it basically bails out right ends up
taking off from there he actually ends
up rescuing a guy who's you know kind of
being uh being beat up a little bit he
takes out the two of the two people who
are beating this dude up and he
basically says he was just playing pool
and then suddenly they jumped him but
the fact that he's wearing a Peter
parser a Peter Parker costume wearing a
Spider-Man costume does not go unnoticed
by this guy and he's like look I
appreciate you saving me but like it's
really in bad taste for you to wear that
costume right now what's more so than
that he's like you know we all need
Heroes but that was Peter Parker's
costume and that's one of the big things
to know when Peter Parker died and and
even Peter Parker is Spider-Man his
identity was known right when when all
that popped off his identity was known
to the world people were like the world
needs to know that this is the kid who
who tried to save everybody who died a
hero that's why the death of Peter
Parker was so massive in the Ultimate
Universe right like imagine for example
that like in the main Marvel Universe
the Marvel Comics that Iron Man dies and
it's this great big huge event that
crosses over every single comic that
they have right it's like the death of
Iron Man you know the Incredible Hulk
tie-in and Captain America tie in and
all that kind of stuff right like
everything ties into just the fact that
Iron Man Died and how everybody's coping
with it that's what the death of Peter
Parker was it was just huge it was
massive because Spider-Man had never
actually been killed off in Marvel
Comics with no intention of bringing him
back right that's just never happened
before right I mean Marvel kind of tried
it with a clone saga but like that was
never gonna happen ah with the Ultimate
Universe it's the way it is Peter
Parker's been dead you know he's like
the the Peter Parker Spider-Man concept
is dead and Miles Morales have taken it
over and has been that way ever since so
it was kind of a big deal it was a huge
deal when it happened but this guy that
the fact that this guy reveals that they
know who Peter Parker is really throws
like the main Marvel Universe Peter
Parker off because his identity is
something that he keeps insanely Coast
guarded right now in the in in Civil War
he revealed it to the world just as kind
of a proof of the fact that he trusted
Iron Man's superhero registration but of
course as we saw in the aftermath of
that brand new day that doctor strange
came along and just magic everybody's
memory of Peter Parker's identity out of
their heads right he's just like new
magic and then nobody remembered that
Peter Parker was Spider-Man and that was
essentially it right that was basically
it that's probably what they're gonna
end up doing in Spider-Man 3 the movie
but the the whole point behind this is
that this throws Peter Parker for a loop
because he's kind of like okay that's
crazy like wherever it is they're
referring to me in the third person so
one this guy doesn't know who I am but
he knows who Peter Parker is so that
means there was a Peter Parker here in
this place what in the world is going on
right now and so what ends up happening
is he's ultimately met by the arrival of
Miles Morales and Miles Morales pops up
and he's just like no way right because
to the eyes of Miles Morales this is the
Ultimate Universe version of Peter
Parker it's like Peter Parker has come
back that's what kind of blew things off
right that's what drive that's what
makes Miles Morales kinda go nuts here
okay so we are picking back up again
with uh Spider-Man part two and this
week we're gonna kind of run through a
whole bunch of Spider-Man related
content mostly because of the fact that
the new Spider-Man games coming out we
kind of want to be done in time for all
of that stuff but um and this one we
pick up with part two right now again
for those of you guys who are just
joining us here Spider-Man is the first
time that Peter Parker from The main
Marvel Universe meets Miles Morales the
new Spider-Man in The Ultimate Universe
right this is a big deal when it first
came out now we ended up having this
happening by way of the fact that uh
Mysterio had basically managed to create
some kind of interdimensional portal and
the result was that when Peter Parker
Came Upon it and ended up fighting
Mysterio Peter Parker ended up being
thrown through right it was kind of
sucked through more than anything else
but Peter Parker passed through it ended
up in the Ultimate Universe what this
does is it wakes up with Mysterio in the
aftermath of that now as soon as
Mysterio comes too his immediate
response is really bro
he's incredibly pissed off right because
he's just like this is the worst thing
now it's not like super complicated or
anything that's one of the great things
about Brian Michael bendus when he was
writing really Ultimate Spider-Man and
Miles Morales Spider-Man I always say
Fitness is better when he's writing kids
or teenagers when it comes to adults
he's not that good but with kids or
teenagers he's amazing right so writing
Miles Morales he was super good at it
but the idea behind this is that from
mysterious perspective he does not want
to run into another situation where
Peter Parker exists that him basically
stumbling across the Ultimate Universe
was a universe where Peter Parker's
Spider-Man didn't really exist Peter
Parker had never heard of Mysterio and
so with you know him you know really
presuming that Miles Morales that he
knew miles existed their mouths could be
somebody he could overcome pretty pretty
quickly right because by and large when
it comes to Marvel Comics villains from
the from the main Marvel Universe are
usually more powerful from villain than
villains from the Ultimate Universe and
even main characters themselves even
somebody like the Phoenix force or like
Thor or Loki they're really powerful
characters in relation to their uh to
their Ultimate Universe counterparts
because the Ultimate Universe was
designed to be more toned down and
realistic even in the realm of comic
books if you're writing a character and
really a series of stories that exist as
close as you can get to the real world
you probably don't want to really see
these wild flights of fantasy when it
comes to ridiculous level of levels of
power right like Marquee of death
different things like that but the whole
idea here is that what you end up having
is Mysterio who basically kind of brings
out this kind of Avatar and this is
basically a version of himself kind of a
robotic version of himself that can go
into the Ultimate Universe in a step
right because if you're Mysterio you
don't want to get yourself killed going
into the Ultimate Universe you send a
robot in your place and so switching
over to Peter and Miles this is one of
the interesting things here albeit a
little strange and the reason why is
because initially Peter doesn't know
what to make of Miles and Miles doesn't
know what to make of Peter right he's
like one of the world's going on and
Peter hasn't figured out that he's in
the Ultimate Universe because he doesn't
know what the Ultimate Universe is he
just knows he's in some other place
right and seemingly picking up pretty
quickly on the fact that he's in some
kind of an alternate Dimension and so
because of this there's a you know kind
of fight that starts to break out
between Peter and Miles because Peter's
like okay you're freaking me out right
because they keep going back and forth
right Peter's like what's the deal here
miles is like you tell me and Peter's
like is it a clone thing and he's like
what's a clone thing it's like you tell
me it's like I thought this was some
kind of Nick Fury test is it a Nick Fury
test and miles is like you tell me and
it's like you're just kind of going back
and forth right so Peter gets frustrated
just a little uh gets a little test and
uh ends up attacking miles right ends up
going after miles but miles for his part
immediately Dodges Spider-Man's webbing
right and so from there what you end up
getting is this really interesting
situation where miles is able to Bob and
weave and duck all of Spider-Man's
attacks and then counter proportionally
now this is where things get a little
wonky right this is where things get a
little you know I don't know how I feel
about that right because keep in mind
miles has not been formally trained by
anybody at Shield yet right in anybody
in the triskelly by Nick Fury or any of
those guys and so he is still in a lot
of ways flying by the seat of his pants
and so the fact that we're kind of
getting this version of Miles who over
his time in being Spider-Man is able to
go toe-to-toe with Peter Parker who's
been playing this role for a very long
time and not only go toe-to-toe managed
to dodge his attacks and then shock him
is a little bit stunning here but no pun
intended it's a little bit stunning here
but the funny thing about this too is we
can also kind of play into it into it
from Peter's perspective that Peter is
not fighting to like beat the crap out
of miles right he's not looking to like
overcome miles he's looking to kind of
do him if anything else I'd probably web
him up or something like that if Peter
were fighting miles in the same vein
that he was fighting somebody like Rhino
or like Dr Octopus or somebody like that
the fight probably would have gone a
much different way and it would have
been over much much faster the reality
is which way this fight would have gone
depends on which character you like more
that's basically what it is right if
you're a fan of Miles you're like oh of
course miles could overcome Peter Parker
if you don't believe me just ask me and
I'll tell you but if you're a fan of
Peter Parker it's the exact same thing
right it's like no Peter Parker
definitely could have gotten the upper
hand on Miles right I mean I know
because I'm right I mean that's that's
kind of how we as comic book fans get we
need no other evidence than our own
opinion and that's basically it now the
funny thing is Miles actually goes to
take the mask off Peter which miles
should know by now is kind of a No-No
that's just something that you don't do
and that leads to Peter basically
reacting you know waking up and then
kicking miles off the ledge of the
building right and then from there
Peter's like dude I think I just killed
this kid
I think I just did this kid in uh I do
not need that on my conscience right I
do not need this on my conscience now
unbeknownst to him of course miles has
initiated his invisibility power but
nonetheless Peter's just kind of like uh
okay I think I killed this kid this is
this is the problem we gotta find this
kid right and then miles pops back up
gets the upper hand on Peter kicks him
and then of course Peter ends up kind of
spinning some webbing out and then from
there he shoots his webbing into miles
mask and Yanks his mask off right and
that's what he's kind of like all right
here it's time for you to come clean
right like how are you Spider-Man what's
going on here like like give me all the
skinny give me all the information now
the responsive miles is you have to give
me my mask back right like anybody out
here could see that I'm Spider-Man and I
have to keep my family and my identity
protected like give me my mask back now
you would expect Peter to respond and
say yeah I kind of understand where
you're coming from that's kind of my
thing too but desperate times call for
desperate measures and Peter needs
information the problem with this is he
didn't really understand why miles got
the upper hand on him the first time and
so he didn't really even think about the
Venom blast this time which miles uses
channels it into the end of the webbing
and then and takes out Peter it's genius
and that was one of the cool things that
made miles so interesting in the early
Comics is when you were reading his
character you could actually watch him
become a biter a better Spider-Man as
you were reading the comic and so with
every single story arc that you read he
was a better version of Spider-Man at
the end of that story than he was before
he started the story right it was really
really cool but with regards to Peter
what you end up getting here is uh is
Miles basically using Peter's web
shooter so I had to kind of Swing them
you know down down to the ground and
they kind of get them onto a roof and
they get them to safety and when they
collapse right he ends up taking the
mask off Peter and he realizes oh my God
this is Peter Parker now for him he
doesn't know this is Peter from the
Marvel Universe from the main Marvel
Universe right he thinks it's like Peter
Parker returned from his universe so
he's like I have no idea what I do here
right and that's what he kind of looks
over to the triskelian and Peter
Parker's taken to the shield
headquarters right from there he meets
with Nick Fury now most of the guys who
read the Ultimate Universe know two
things about Nick Fury the first one is
that he was based on Samuel Jackson
right in fact Samuel Jackson actually
threatened to sue Marvel but they ended
up letting him play the role of Nick
Fury in the MCU so the lawsuit never
happened right why we got Samuel Jackson
Nick Fury but the other thing about this
is that Nick Fury is highly skeptical
right he is a super suspicious guy and
so when he starts asking questions when
he starts asking him like well at least
when he refers to him as Peter and
Peter's like do you know me and he's
like I know the name you know and it's
that kind of a thing he started the two
of them start talking to each other and
it's kind of a cool bit of a
conversation here right because Peter
even makes reference to the fact that
like I know your eye patch but it's one
of these little these little tidbit
things but when he asks him like you
know are you Peter Parker it's like well
it's not that straightforward and it's
like okay well then give me give me an
answer right give me this one
hypothetical answer that you have and
Peter basically reiterates this whole
fight with Mysterio then passing through
the portal and then Indigo here and all
that kind of stuff and Nick Fury is kind
of like huh okay I mean I could probably
buy that story it's so far-fetched it
might just be true right it's just it's
one of those things so he just kind of
ends up giving Peter credibility here
now the reality of this is that business
does this just for the sake of keeping
the story moving forward under any other
comic in the Ultimate Universe Nick Fury
would be like no I'm not buying that
you're gonna stay in this cell until you
tell me what's actually going on and he
would legitimately leave him there Nick
free would have done that if you if you
if you sat down if this happened in the
ultimates and it was anybody else
besides Spider-Man if it was ultimates
or like the ultimate Fantastic Four or
the ultimate X-Men Nick Fury would be
like no man I'm not buying into that
that nonsense that crazy Malarkey not
buying into that any of that stuff right
so he would just leave him there but
bindis does this for the sake of keeping
the story moving forward what he ends up
doing is basically handing Peter over to
Miles and say okay it's your all's job
to go do your own thing right you're
all's job to get this whole thing sorted
out and find out what's going on and so
what Peter does is by virtue of what
Nick Fury told him the way that miles is
acting that kind of thing he starts to
put two and two together and so what he
does is he really kind of asks the big
question like tell me kid in this
universe is Peter Parker dead right is
Peter Parker not alive here anymore and
that's what's kind of nuts is because
before miles can really give him an
answer and explain everything both of
them are shot through the helicopter by
uh this Avatar of Mysterio and in turn
miles basically saves both of them and
then kind of takes both guys or really
takes him and the pilot down to their
safety right but basically Mysterio is
here and starts launching his attack
against uh against Peter and Miles so
this is when we go from Miles Morales me
Peter Parker to Miles fighting Peter to
Miles and Peter teaming up
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are picking back up again
with Spider-Man uh I almost hit
Spider-Man 2 with Spider-Man we're
picking back up with Miles Morales and
Peter Parker now this is kind of a
three-pronged event right like the first
time and the first issue they met and
the second issue they fought and this
one they team up so it's kind of a cool
a cool bit of Storytelling here right
but in the instance where they had
initially fought each other and things
that kind of popped off and they were
sort of coming to coming to terms and
you know with regards to this reality
they're suddenly met by this this Avatar
of uh of Mysterio now again this is kind
of the robot slash you know what really
just straight robot that Mysterio is
using he is in the main Marvel Universe
but he's piloting this and it's moving
around in the Ultimate Universe right
and so because of that as soon as it
takes down the helicopter that Peter
Parker and Miles Morales were in the two
of them start to team up to fight up
Mysterio the problem with this is that
that Miles Morales has never really
fought anybody like Mysterio before and
even Mysterio as he exists in the main
Marvel universe doesn't really exist the
same way in the Ultimate Universe to
kind of give you guys some perspective
of the big differences is between these
two things because I believe by this
point Doctor Strange is dead um there
came a point in the Ultimate Universe
where Doctor Strange fought dormammu and
in the main Marvel Universe doctor
strain is fought door Mamu a multitude
of times and one pretty much every
single time in the Ultimate Universe he
fights him once and dies it's it's nuts
like he's he's painfully outclassed in
comparison to the power that door Mamu
has like he kills him with a quickness
and that's basically it but that happens
so incredibly fast because you're
talking about Mysterio who still
maintains his ability to create
Illusions despite using a kind of Avatar
form you end up having uh Peter Parker
who picks up on what's going on now it
took him a moment to realize it because
he's like so many weird is going on
right it's a more more powerful strain
of the illusion that he normally uses
but what he ends up doing is Conjuring
all of Spider-Man's villains and the the
things that that Miles Morales fears the
most right so basically their greatest
fears between the two of them and with
this happening you really only ever see
the Scorpion from the Ultimate Universe
you see uncle Aaron the prowler from the
Ultimate Universe and Omega Red from the
Ultimate Universe but you only really
see those because those are the only
really the villains that Miles Morales
has fought so for for Peter Parker it's
it's a whole host of stuff right it's a
whole host of things Green Goblin and Dr
Octopus and all that stuff but that's
what makes us so Bonkers is because of
the fact that Miles doesn't really know
how to navigate this now this kind of
Illusion that Mysterio creates that's
one of the big things to understand his
Illusions can be tangible if they're
powerful enough they can be tangible and
that's one of the big differences is
that in the early days if I remember
correctly in the early days his
Illusions were more or less intangible
right so he could trick you into
believing you were somewhere but he
couldn't really make things interact
with you in this instance he can and
it's really kind of been that way for a
number of years in Marvel Comics but
Mysterio uses his powers to quite
literally have these guys attack uh
Miles Morales and Spider-Man and Peter
Parker right so it's like Venom and his
Carnage it's all these guys and this is
incredibly dangerous because these are
forces of Miles isn't used to facing off
against but this is one of the big
differences here is that Miles hasn't
really faced off against Mysterio before
but at the same time this kind of magic
doesn't necessarily see exist inside the
Ultimate Universe now this may seem like
it would naturally work against Miles
Morales he's basically being exposed to
something that he hasn't really seen
before and wouldn't really know how to
navigate those Waters but instead of
doing what Peter Parker seems to be
doing here which is kind of overthinking
it to a degree instead miles actually
manages to get the upper hand and
basically incapacitate Mysterio
temporarily you know if for no other
reason than to basically take down his
Avatar form and then essentially destroy
it right like destroy that that body
because miles picks up on the fact this
is the reason why it's happening now
again this is one of those instances in
the Ultimate Spider-Man comics where
people were a little finicky they were
like I mean I have a hard time believing
that miles would be able to pick up on
this and Peter Parker couldn't you're
talking about two characters from two
different realities who navigate Waters
differently there were when this when
the story first came out there was one
group of people who looked at this and
said okay the only reason miles is able
to figure this out on his own is because
business is writing it and bindis is
pushing miles and really wants him to be
like the new Ultimate Universe
Spider-Man and of what use would his
character be if he didn't have some kind
of caveat over Peter Parker from you
know Peter Parker in general right even
from the main Marvel Universe it's one
of these interesting Concepts one of
these interesting quagmires but again
you know with regards to Mysterio he's
one of these villains where by all
standards of measurement he would have
gotten the upper hand on Miles Morales
because what makes Mysterio's uh you
know his his powers so incredibly potent
is he's much like Mastermind or somebody
like Charles Xavier not in so much as
the powers he possesses he's just an
Illusionist right he doesn't really have
telepathy or anything like that but much
like those guys his powers can totally
envelope you and convince you that
you're somewhere that you're not right
Mysterio gets his hands on you he can
convince you that you're a world away
you know and and you're in you know some
Pirate Land and you're fighting against
Pirates or something like that you know
the whether or not you're able to
actually pick up on that are two
distinctly different things right
creating that illusion if you're of
sound mind you'll immediately know that
something's off right regardless when
everything kind of Pops off Peter Parker
actually ends up taking off he doesn't
leave the universe he just goes to
explore it and what you end up having
are the ultimates who arrive here on the
scene with Miles Morales now one of the
big things that goes on here is again
because these characters were designed
to be a lot more toned down than the
versions that we saw in the old the
universe that Tony Stark doesn't really
know how to navigate this this
technology right like in the main Marvel
Universe he would have picked it up
right off the bat and just been like
okay so here's what's going on with this
instead in the Ultimate Universe he his
intelligence is a little more grounded
right so it's not as though he's just
wildly out there as intelligent as the
story he needs him to be instead it's a
little more grounded here so he
recognized it insofar as it's an
exceedingly you know advanced form of
technology and that it's an avatar
that's basically being used by you know
this Mysterio guy to control you know
control this this avatar version from
someplace else but in terms of being
able to reverse engineer it almost
instantaneously that doesn't happen here
right that doesn't really take place
here now for Miles part of course he
ends up asking Nick Fury where the other
Spider-Man go and fury responses he went
out there to explore things and that's
the nature of this right when you're
when you're someone like Spider-Man and
you face off against Mysterio and you've
gone through his Illusions so many times
the biggest struggle he has here is
trying to figure out whether any of this
is real or false that's the biggest
struggle he has at the moment because
you know you got to kind of think of
this from Peter's perspective he was in
his own universe he was facing off
against Mysterio found himself yanked
through a portal ended up in this new
reality where he's dead there's a new
Spider-Man that took his place ah and
that there's a there's a Nick Fury there
you know who seemingly allowed the two
of them to team up and then Mysterio's
Avatar appears he ends up facing off
against all of his villains even though
they're Illusions and then of course
Miles Morales ends up destroying that
that Avatar and now Peter is basically
exploring in his mind all of this could
be the illusion and that's the truth of
the thing right that's the truth of the
thing here when you're facing off
against Mysterio this could all be
illusion it's entirely possible that
vendus could have ended this story and
it was all just one big huge illusion
created by by a Mysterio and it would
work it would be believable because he's
done it before right that's the
advancement of Mysterio's Illusions is
that it just it screws with your head so
incredibly badly but as we know Peter
Parker is actually in the Ultimate
Universe and so he basically starts
tracking different things down right he
goes to the place it would have been his
apartment he ends up finding a corner
store he asked him like how long has
this been here she's like I don't know
how long have you worked here I've
worked here two years you know and he's
like okay so there was never an
apartment building here here you know
like they're like there was never an
apartment here and so basically he never
stayed here the other thing that ends up
happening after he you know beats up
some guy who runs into the place and
robs it is he asks her for you know for
a tablet that can help him access the
internet and when he does he finds an
article that the Spider-Man in this
universe really did die here and that it
really that everybody really knew that
he was Peter Parker that he was a high
school student from Queens and so it's
one of these things where it's kind of
like I really am in a universe where I'm
dead the other part of that is of course
she has this little necklace around her
neck and of course is her way of paying
respects to Peter Parker as Spider-Man
and then he's like you need to tell me
exactly what happened to Peter Parker in
this universe and so what we end up
doing is we basically end up picking up
uh you know some period of time later
with Aunt May and with Gwen Stacy from
the Ultimate Universe and Peter Parker
shows up on their doorstep right like
literally just shows up there and this
is one of the most amazing things here
it's one of the most amazing moments
because this is Peter Parker coming to
grips with Gwen Stacy who is still alive
in this universe and on May and having
to face the fact that in their mind he's
dead and so it's kind of like wow like
this is one of those things it's a hyper
emotional story if you're a Peter Parker
fan right it's it's kind of nuts it's
Peter Parker re-encountering uh Aunt May
and Gwen Stacy it's kind of nuts
okay we're picking back up again with uh
Spider-Man which is the conclusion of
the story where Peter Parker meets Miles
Morales for the very very first time
right Peter Parker from The main Marvel
Universe meets The Ultimate Spider-Man
Miles Morales and the whole idea behind
this is that we pick up with Peter
Parker following his kind of encounter
alongside uh miles with Mysterio who use
basically use the kind of robot version
of himself to move into the Ultimate
Universe or to travel to the Ultimate
Universe uh Peter Parker is essentially
traveled to meet uh the ultimate
universe's version of Gwen Stacy and
Mary Jane Watson now keep in mind the
last time they saw Spider-Man it was
their version of Peter Parker and he
died and largely there was just kind of
the grieving process that went into it
now one of the things that we talked
about in the early Miles Morales Comics
that we did is that there did come a
point when miles took on the Spider-Man
costume and was met by Aunt Mei and and
Gwen Stacy and they were kind of like
look if you're gonna do this understand
that you're living up to a legacy much
bigger than yourself right you don't
just simply put on the Spider-Man
costume and do your thing you're living
up to the Legacy that my nephew created
uh and you stand for everything he stood
for so this is not a thing to take
lightly right so it was kind of
initially they were against it but it's
one of these things we're just kind of
like okay you know we can sort of get on
board once they realize the character of
Miles Morales and what he had to offer
but the problem with this is that when
Peter shows up he's wearing the original
Spider-Man costume and as soon as opme
sees this she gets pissed right because
he basically showed his face and her
thought is as some kind of a some kind
of a joke right Gwen Stacy shows up and
starts kicking the crap out of out of
Peter Parker thinking that he's pulling
a stunt too and it's not until miles
shows up and says no no no no it's
really actually Peter right it's not
somebody pulling a pulling a trick or
something like that not somebody being a
jerk I don't really know of a reasonable
human being that would show up on the
doorstep of a woman and like basically
two chicks who lost somebody close to
them dressed as that person right I mean
if somebody were to do that I would
wholly like I would stand by and just
watch them get the crap kicked out of
him I'd record it and then just be like
yeah man this guy kind of had it coming
like that'd be my response
I'd be like yeah man like they were kind
of a dick they sort of had this comment
right nobody do anything let them get
their Just Desserts but uh this is
actually Peter right this is actually
Peter Parker here and when miles comes
to his rescue that's when Aunt May and
uh Gwen Stacy basically start to listen
right and Peter's initial response is
like like I thought initially I died I
thought something happened like I didn't
really know what was going on how I
ended up here you know I've only
recently been putting the pieces
together I never should have come here
right I never should have come here to
this place you know I'm sorry I did this
to you and then basically Aunt May
passes out right now at that point we
switch over to the Ultimate Universe
Tony Stark and Nick Fury right now Nick
Fury we've talked about before Ultimate
Universe Iron Man we've never really had
a big discussion about one of the big
things to understand here is that
Ultimate Iron Man when he first showed
up was designed to be a more grounded
version of Tony Stark from the main
Marvel Universe right so not as
intelligent because even Tony in the
main Marvel Universe his intelligence
even for the realm of comics borderlines
questionable right like how could a
person possibly be that smart this
version of Tony is really smart but he
is a version of intelligence we would
expect like to see here in the real
world right hence the nature of the
Ultimate Universe kind of reflection of
the real world the way it exists now and
so he's not really able to pick up or
really figure out what Mysterio what's
what's going on with Mysterio's
character right how to reverse engineer
the circuitry where the signals coming
from any all that kind of stuff the the
reality of this is there's an infinite
number of universes out there right and
Tony just doesn't have the ability to
trace his signal back to its origin
point now if this were in the main
Marvel Universe the main Marvel Tony
Stark would have figured it out like
that but he would have figured it out so
fast because it's what the story called
for it but the idea of the Ultimate
Universe was to write more realistic
stories right and really if you're
talking about an infinite number of
universes there really wouldn't be a way
to trace the signal all the way back to
its origin point because it's not like
it's a rope that leaves from the main
Marvel Universe and all they have to do
is just follow the breadcrumbs to get to
its location it doesn't really work that
way at least not for for anybody here
and so at the end of the day Tony
doesn't really have any answers here
he's like the only way for me to really
get some answers is to talk to that
alternate reality version of Spider-Man
to talk to Peter Parker it's the only
way for me to really figure out what it
is that's going on here now the funny
comment he makes is I'm surprised that
you let Miles Morales run around with
Peter Parker right I figured he would
have cracked him over the head thrown
him into a Hole uh and basically grabbed
like the the main Peter and done the
same thing right kind of you know kept
Miles Morales under wraps so that he
wouldn't really have any idea what's
going on and then basically took Peter
and and just kind of locked him up but
the idea behind this is that Fury really
feels a bit of you know regret when it
comes to Peter right Peter was never
properly trained to become a superhero
he was never properly trained he was
never really inducted the way that he
was supposed to be he was just kind of
allowed to do his thing and that led to
his eventual death and and Nick Fury
felt a lot of responsibility for that
that's why when you go and you read
cataclysm that there's a lot of focus
put on Nick Theory and the guilt he
feels for the death of Peter Parker
because when he could have trained him
or he could have helped him to become a
better hero he didn't instead it was
just kind of him doing his thing and so
with that guilt in mind along with
promises that he made it's kind of like
we're just gonna let them work it out
together right which is actually the
right move the best move for Nick Fury
to make is really for Peter on Meg When
Stacy to all kind of come to terms with
this on their own and so once amme wakes
up you basically have Peter like telling
stories you know to to miles into Gwen
Stacy them sharing stories with him that
kind of a thing and kind of going back
and forth right and Peter's coming to
this realization there's massive
differences between this reality and the
one that he's from now we as the reader
know that one of the funny things that
goes on is Gwen Stacy kind of starts
poking and prodding and is like is there
a version of me in your universe and
Peter's like yeah but she's a little bit
older than you are you know she's about
my age and she's like well I mean you
know like are you dating her and Peter's
like I mean not really like I'm
basically dating Mary Jane Watson right
which is what Gwen Stacy calls and then
as soon as as soon as this kind of
explanation goes on that Mary Jane is
like a supermodel where she's not in the
Ultimate Universe right she's just like
a nerdy girl what it's like she's a
supermodel and all that kind of stuff
like when Stacy's kind of shocked to
find out that like Mary Jane Watson is
this hugely popular world-renowned model
and it's kind of like wow that's a
little crazy but when she starts asking
uh what about me right like what am I
then like what's going on with me
Peter's like wait we should we should
probably talk about something else
I don't have the heart to tell you that
the Green Goblin threw you off a bridge
and I shot my my webbing your foot and
broke your neck in the process up
because that's basically what happened I
don't care what anybody says she was not
dead before Spider-Man got there I don't
care what anybody says but uh you know
it's it's kind of an interesting theme
because it's like there were parts of
his reality he doesn't really want to
divulge because who knows how Gwen Stacy
would react if it was like well you're
dead and I'm the reason why then it's
kind of like get out of this house right
you know I don't want you here but it's
really kind of new to her to learn a
really fascinating for her to learn now
there's a whole other worlds and
dimensions out there now for her part
Aunt May is a lot more reserved here
right she's not nearly as excited as
Gwen Stacy is you know she's kind of
breaking bracing herself with the idea
that it's not actually Peter Parker
that's like well we don't really know if
it's Peter Parker we don't really know
if it's him right we don't know if
that's the case it could be somebody
else pretending to be him now and in
fact like it really is him we know that
Miles Morales believes that Gwen Stacy
believes it but Aunt May's doing this
because in her heart of hearts if she
gives into this and then it turns out to
be false she'd lose it right like it
would just be the most crushing
experience because for her when she kind
of asked Peter you know what led you to
be to become this person right when he
kind of starts talking to her about like
Uncle Ben Uncle Ben's the reason why he
does this that okobin of course is dead
in his reality but the fact that that he
could have saved Uncle Ben and he didn't
is the reason why he became a superhero
the way that he did and the idea that he
could he could basically help other
people and in a lot of ways a tone for
his past mistake he basically runs off
the statement with great power and then
she finishes it comes great
responsibility now it should be must
come great responsibility the fact that
this is a lesson that Peter was taught
by Uncle Ben tells Aunt May everything
she needs to know that it really is him
and that's where she kind of gives
herself over and says we thought like
like we lost you right we lost you and
we didn't even get to say goodbye and
that's the important thing here right
that's the important thing to understand
that's why Aunt May kept herself
reserved in this part right because if
she had said like okay yeah you're
probably Peter and let her whole self
believe it and then it turned out to
just be some alternate reality version
of Peter who was evil or something like
that but it wasn't like the this
alternate reality counterpart to the one
that she knew which is to say a good guy
who fights a good fight and does what
Heroes do then it would have broken her
in her entirety right like the the
inability of her to say goodbye the
chance that she the fact that she never
got to tell Peter that she was proud of
him that she loved him but to never say
like to never be able to say I'm sorry
or any of that stuff right to basically
like confess her or to to kind of get to
say her last goodbyes to him is
something that's always haunted her
having Peter hear this alternate reality
version of Peter even though she knows
this not her actual nephew she knows is
not that Peter Parker from The Ultimate
Universe gives her a chance to
effectively say goodbye right to say her
goodbyes and and you know indirectly say
it to Peter Parker from Ultimate
Universe to give her closure it's
basically what this does something that
she's never had this entire time and so
Miles Morales looking at the window
realizes uh okay Shield's on their way
we need to go right because Shield is a
lot more seedy in the Ultimate Universe
than they are in the main Marvel
Universe in the main Marvel Universe
they're still kind of jerks but like
they're more inclined to work with you
than against you in the Ultimate
Universe they're like a like a like a
police force almost right I mean not
specifically but in terms of like how
they function right like they do their
thing and all there are just people who
stand in the way is basically all that
it is but of course Peter ends up saying
goodbye to uh to everybody here and then
of course he ends up getting in the car
with uh Nick Fury Miles Morales and it's
kind of a funny thing because Nick Fury
asked like is there a Nick Theory where
you come from and he's like yeah but
he's kind of a white guy and then like
Nick Fury is like sorry to hear that man
which is kind of a funny thing but again
it gives Aunt May the closure she needs
and that's why when the story came out
it was so huge it was wrapping up all
these plot threads right all these
little things that have been left
hanging and the reality is that if
anybody but Brian Michael Bendis had
taken this over we probably would have
never seen this right but Benda started
off with her with the Ultimate
Spider-Man he originally created it it
makes sense that he would basically end
it here and kind of continue things on
with Miles and that's why Spider-Man is
so important it's one part wrapping up
plot threads that bendus never got to
wrap up after the death of Peter Parker
in the Ultimate Universe and the
cataclysm story and it was a way to kind
of officially transition into miles and
we'll find more you'll find out more why
that's the case when we get once we get
to the the end of this but when he when
he really meets with you know Tony Stark
he's kind of like okay so there's a few
differences here like one the Tony Stark
in my universe stopped drinking a while
ago which Nick Fury loves and two it's
obvious this guy's not as smart and so
with with Tony kind of being like look
like I need to know where his home is I
need to know where your universe is uh
when Peter starts to point him in that
direction then it turns into okay then
we could at the very least figure out
how to get you back right we can figure
you know we can figure out how to remove
first engineer this stuff now make no
mistake Tony Stark's not doing this out
of the goodness of his heart Tony starts
doing this one part because he was
directed by Nick Fury but two because he
can get something out of it right I mean
this is a level of technology that Tony
just doesn't have access to being able
to attain this technology and use it for
his own ends is a huge benefit right
it's something that he desperately wants
here and so once once they're basically
looking at the broadcast that Mysterio
has been putting out you know over the
internet you know all day long and for
how many days he's been here miles picks
up on the fact that one of these
buildings is actually in Brooklyn right
he's like one of these villages in
Brooklyn I'm familiar with it and so
they know exactly where it is Mysterio
is operating out of how they know his
base of operations once they locate that
Nick Fury calls in everyone and when I
say everyone I mean an entire Shield
Strike Team alongside Spider-Man and
alongside the ultimate Thor
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are picking back up again with the
conclusion of Spider-Man yes we are we
are wrapping up the Spider-Man event uh
and this is probably the single most
important part of the story not
necessarily because of what's happened
so far but because of the future of
Miles Morales so what we end up doing
here is we initially pick up with
Mysterio a Mysterio offering from the
same problem that every super villain
suffers from stupidity so the
stereo so the idea behind this with
Mysterio is that he comes to the
realization that he actually
unintentionally defeated Spider-Man
dealt with Spider-Man being whisked off
into this other dimension where Peter
Parker in that reality is dead that it
leaves no Spider-Man in this universe
right in the main Marvel Universe there
is no Peter Parker here right he's off
in the Ultimate Universe somewhere and
it was something that Mysterio had not
really thought of before and now he
realizes it like man dude okay like I
actually defeated Spider-Man but then
the question becomes why isn't it enough
right like why is it not enough he's
like I have to see it right I have to
see him suffer and die I'll just take a
peek for myself just for one moment now
this is Brian Michael Bendis being Brian
Michael bendus if it were me writing the
story it would be like oh man dude I won
cool the end and that would be it right
it would be Mysterio realizing he
basically got the upper hand on Peter
Parker and there's no no more Spider-Man
here such as it is Ben is wanted to tell
the story and so so basically Mysterio
comes to the realization that he wants
to actually see Spider-Man suffer and
die and so he reopened he basically
reactivates the portal and takes a peek
inside only for webbing to come flying
out
and eviction basically attach itself to
him and then of course you have Peter
Parker you have Miles Morales and the
ultimates team who's there right the
Ultimate Avengers who are all there and
it's kind of like well crap right like
well damn like that's that's basically
it right like okay I mean who could have
possibly seen that coming the cool thing
about this though is that one thing to
understand with Mysterio is he's usually
always got an ace up his sleeve and
that's one of the things that makes him
so dangerous right and so where you have
Nick Fury you've got the rest of the
guys who are kind of like cool the day's
saved keep in mind they're not used to
the kind of villains you have in the
main Marvel Universe where somehow they
always have some kind of an escape plan
or something like that remember the main
Marvel universe is a lot less realistic
than the Ultimate Universe was and so
Mysterio immediately types away and just
starts releasing a whole host of these
chemicals and sets off an explosion and
when that happens basically everybody
hears like Iron Man Nick Fury Miles
Morales all these various guys are met
by what are essentially their worst
nightmares right it's literally what
they're exposed to using the power of
Mysterio he exposes all of them to their
worst nightmares right so you've got all
the ultimates who are dead at the hands
of Tony Stark which of course is
definitely an allusion to what we saw in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe uh you've
got Nick Fury who's watching the world
on fire watching the world burn Green
Goblin has killed Aunt May in the eye in
front of uh I'm sorry really Dr Octopus
and Green Goblin have killed Aunt May in
front of Spider-Man and then you've got
the prowler who killed uh Miles Morales
mother and father and so because of that
where everybody else is kind of
succumbing to this miles sort of
succumbs to it a little bit but then
manages to get the upper hand on it even
if only for a moment and when that
happens he realizes Mysterio's making a
break for the portal and he tackles
Mysterio Now by all standards of
measurement miles should it should have
been 100 incapacitated here and again
that's kind of the critique of bindis
right then this is just well of course
miles wild has to be on top he's the guy
that I'm riding right now he's the main
Spider-Man we can't have him lose right
so it's kind of like okay you know it's
sort of you just kind of go with it in
this story right it's just kind of the
way the business does it but where you
end up having Mysterio who of course
uses powers on Miles yet again he almost
gets the upper hand miles Dodges the
attack goes invisible and the Mysterio
trying to figure out what happens ends
up being attacked by Miles again now
again this has kind of been just
basically saying like this is how
capable miles is now the reality of this
is that while this was kind of I
wouldn't say far-fetched but kind of
like what in the world's going on here
you know back in the day in this day and
age it's common practice and it kind of
makes sense I think that with this story
and and Miles being able to overcome
Mysterio so fast despite Mysterio's
abilities was really more of just been
just wanting to tell the story as
opposed to just kind of letting it play
out organically in reality having
somebody like Mysterio was probably not
the best bet it probably should have
been somebody more like Dr Octopus
because Mysterio's powers are not
limited to just some kind of tentacles
attached to his back that that go after
you that he messes with your mind he
messes with your head and so there isn't
really a whole lot of reason to believe
that miles would somehow be able to
overcome this so quickly right if you're
trying to maintain that kind of comic
book lore that we're used to and kind of
maintain consistency then you know it's
something you would kind of expect but
with uh Peter Parker able to overcome it
as well alongside miles they take out
Mysterio pretty quickly right he's
defeated pretty fast as so from that
point what they end up doing is actually
keeping Mysterio inside the Ultimate
Universe and the reason why is because
Mysterio now knows that Peter Parker
Spider-Man and so it kind of creates
this situation where Peter's like okay
cool yeah man hold on to him I
appreciate it guys thanks for looking
out it's kind of the Shady thing to do
but this is really the most important
moment that comes out of this right
which is why we kind of more or less
ham-fisted our way through this there's
a point where Peter and miles are
talking and Peter basically thanks him
for keeping the legacy of Spider-Man
going and when miles asks him like does
that mean that I have your blessing
Peter's like absolutely this was Brian
Michael Bendis giving a big middle
finger to the naysayers and we talked
about that before that when miles first
showed up there were a lot of people who
were really pissy about the fact that
Peter Parker in the Ultimate Universe
had been killed and they wanted they
didn't want miles they wanted Peter
Parker the responsive business is you
already have Peter Parker you've had him
for like 50 years right you've had Peter
Parker for a long long time you need to
get over yourselves right it's time for
a new Spider-Man it's time to kind of
continue on this story focusing on
somebody else we can't do that in the
main Marvel Universe we because Peter
Parker is etched in stone forevermore
the Spider-Man in the main Marvel
Universe we can't change that Marvel
editorial won't let me change it and
even if I wanted to it'd be a terrible
idea to do it anyway but in the Ultimate
Universe I created this character Bendis
giveth bendus take it and taketh away
and that's kind of his that's kind of a
stance on that and so when you had a lot
of people who were giving him Flack and
really complaining a lot on the the
various Forum boards and social media
different things like that about Miles
Morales taking over the role of
Spider-Man in The Ultimate Universe this
was really been to sing no he's not
going anywhere right if what you
expected me to do was to basically give
in acquiesce and admit defeat and say
Hey you know you you 50 comic book fans
who sound like 5 million obviously you
guys don't like miles morale so let me
just get rid of him and bring back Peter
Parker if that's what you were expecting
then I'm sorry you're gravely mistaken
that's not what's going to happen and so
we ended up just getting miles moral
Alice going forward and so it's one of
these things where with with Miles kind
of getting the official blessing of
Peter Parker that you have this moment
where Nick Fury kind of pulls him aside
and says you got his Blessing man like
you earned it kid right if that's
Spider-Man the real true Spider-Man
gives you his Blessing then you're good
right just go forward and do your
superhero thing so it's really not
anymore of Nick Fury kind of questioning
miles anymore kind of looking at him
with a skewed eye or really the only eye
he can look at him at uh look at him
with and just kind of you know his one
his one good eye kind of look at him
with a skewed eye and then just kind of
being like is he really gonna be a good
Spider-Man at this point you know he
kind of goes forward with a whole new
level of confidence that he didn't
really have before and that's kind of a
cool thing because what you do is you
switch over to Peter Parker himself back
home right back in his own apartment
he's like Miles Morales miles morals I
wonder if we have a Miles Morales in the
main Marvel Universe and then it ends
now of course we know as far as I'm
aware that's not true in in Marvel
Comics right the story was told like
eight years ago so we know it's not
really true at the time this was written
everybody wanted to know if it was true
or not it was like the biggest biggest
Cliffhanger of like a decade right like
I wonder if it's really I wonder if they
really do have a miles where else in the
main Marvel Universe and it's like I
wonder what's gonna happen with that
right it's kind of crazy but
okay so we are covering probably the
most important Miles Morales story in
the history of Marvel Comics but also
one of the more controversial stories
that Marvel had done in the history of
Marvel in recent years which is Ultimate
end now a little bit of backstory
because this does tie into Secret Wars
and is a part of Secret Wars so for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with how Secret Wars unfolded in 2015
which seems to be the version that we're
going to be getting when it comes to the
secret Wars film in the MCU that this
all started with a variety of things
right you'll find a link to the entire
playlist in the comments section but
what this did is it basically gave us
the collapse of the Multiverse now I'm
not going to go into detail in terms of
how all that happened check out the
video for that but what is important
here is that with the collapse of the
Multiverse Doctor Doom had basically
seized the power of the beyonders for
himself which effectively made him God
and in doing so what he ended up
basically doing was pulling together
different pieces of alternate realities
across the Multiverse and combining them
into a kind of Patchwork called battle
world and so you literally have all
these different alternate realities just
kind of sit side by side so you have
like the Marvel Zombies universe and
then like right next to it is the Age of
Ultron Universe where Ultron conquered
everything right it's just this small
isolated pocket and you can go from one
place to the next although you're not
supposed to right like they're not
supposed to cross from what's called a
domain so you're not supposed to leave
your domain and go to a different one
and so what matters here and what's
important here is that this entire story
takes place within the confines of
battle World itself but there are going
to be things that people who are
familiar with Secret Wars are going to
be asking about I will clarify all that
stuff by the time we get to the end of
the video but what this does is it
initially opens up with the Ultimate
Universe and the main Marvel Universe
meeting and talking now this is kind of
cool because what had happened here at
the very beginning of Secret Wars in
issue number zero is you had the
Ultimate Universe and the main Marvel
universe as the last two universes in
existence everything else had basically
been wiped out they were on a collision
course it was the final incursion they
were all fighting each other and then
everything blinked right because of
Doctor Doom and all that stuff
everything basically collided it blinked
and then battle world came into
existence so one thing that I do want to
establish here is that like most people
across the entirety of the battle World
Secret Wars event most people don't
actually know the truth of what Dr Doom
did all they know is the life that Dr
Doom gave them and the fact that Dr Doom
rules from on hot and that's it that's
really all they know and so what's kind
of crazy here is Bendis sort of takes
his own turn and again what makes sense
of all of this he establishes that there
was basically a kind of dimensional Rift
that had been established in the
ultimate universe that it effectively
combined the Ultimate Universe and the
main Marvel universe together into one
single domain that they used to be
separate now this is where things get a
little murky because what ends up
happening here is we're visited or at
least we see the arrival of Peter Parker
at this giant Gathering now there's also
familiar faces here right like Scott
Summers Emma Frost so on and so forth
but Peter Parker showing up here and
meeting with everybody initially he's
just kind of obsessed about the fact
that everybody seems to know his
identity the bigger concern here that
they have is that because the main
Marvel Universe and because the Ultimate
Universe were at one point two different
domains but their dimensional tampering
led to the domains combining that Dr
Doom may very well become aware of what
it is that they've done and that if he
does there's only one of two
possibilities either he allows it to
sort of continue on and just sort of do
its thing which presents a dangerous
precedent because it means that other
people in other domains can start
experimenting with dimensional Rifts and
potentially discover the truth of what
Dr Doom did or Dr Doom will intervene in
some capacity and so this kind of splits
the group in half those who say that
they need to report their findings to
doom and others who say they don't and
in fact this really seems to be a stark
contrast no pun intended between both
versions of Tony Stark and so this is
where we get this kind of cool
explanation because we actually learn
the basis behind this portal now if
you've been reading the Ultimate
Universe or at least you were at this
point in time you know all of this right
so just bear with me for people who
don't so what happened here at a distant
point in the past is that when Peter
Parker in the Ultimate Universe died
Miles Morales became the new Spider-Man
and initially fans weren't overly
receptive to it and so in order to just
kind of put the kibosh on that and to
establish that Miles wasn't going
anywhere Brian Michael Bendis who was
riding miles at the time wrote a story
called Spider-Man and this involved the
opening of a portal which I want to say
was by the vulture but I'm not going to
swear to that that basically saw Peter
Parker from The main Marvel Universe
crossing over into the Ultimate Universe
and that's how he and Miles met for the
very first time they had a kind of
adventure together and then when miles
told Peter that the Peter Parker in his
reality had died the main Marvel
Universe Spider-Man gave miles his
Blessing and said you now have my
blessing to become the Spider-Man in
this universe carry on the legacy of
your reality's version of Peter Parker
gold go forth and be a superhero and it
was basically been just telling all the
people who were not fans of miles to
shut up and he wasn't going anywhere and
it worked but what this story
establishes is that the portal never
actually was shut down and so what ended
up happening is the portal effectively
exploded outward and then merged the
Ultimate Universe and the main Marvel
Universe into one single reality and
they've been here ever since right now
this is where things are kind of cool
and I think this is a good chance to
explain this the way that secret Wars
initially unfolded is that when it came
to the collapse of the Multiverse there
was no main Marvel Universe anymore and
there was no Ultimate Universe anymore
right like there was nothing it was
simply just those superheroes who
survived and those superheroes who were
plucked from what few realities remained
by Doctor Doom and thrown on to battle
world what Brian Michael Bendis is
establishing here is that within battle
World itself is a main Marvel Universe
and an Ultimate Universe it was
basically Bendis trying to do his own
thing and sort of wrap up the entirety
of the Marvel Multiverse in his own way
but the thing about this is that once
the groups separate and they go their
own ways this leads to the arrival of
the Thor Court they are by extension the
law of Doom right so whenever they come
down and they say this is going to
happen everybody in battle World treats
it as Doom's work because the
alternative is to be killed by the Thor
court and in fact that's exactly what
happens that when they're told by the
Thor core itself do not mess with this
dimensional gate leave it alone right
have no involvement here whatsoever so
sad says the word of Doom Hawkeye
challenges it why did Hawkeye says no
that's not gonna happen right we're
going to do whatever it is that we need
to do and the Thor Corps kills him on
the spot literally just eradicates him
on the spot now that's one thing to
understand is under any normal
circumstance Thor could be rivaled by
any number of of heroes or villains who
are out there given varying degrees of
power the Thor core's power was elevated
by Dr Doom to allow them to overcome
virtually any foe out there the
exception to this was when they met
Thanos when Thanos survived the collapse
of the Multiverse and he showed up with
like the the col obsidian right like the
black order and like the different
villains and just demolish the Thor core
which was amazing
apocalypse did it too this is why I tell
you guys you need to check out the
playlist in the comment section after
this video is done because Avengers New
Avengers Secret Wars The Greatest Story
Ever Told in the history of Marvel
Comics it's phenomenal but of course
with Hawkeye being killed and the groups
coming to the realization that at least
for the moment if they are gonna mess
with this portal they have to keep it
Hush Hush they can't just go out there
and just sort of do it brazenly you end
up having main Marvel Universe Iron Man
and Ultimate Iron Man meeting with each
other and kind of having a bit of a sit
down right in a bit of a conversation
and in fact it's one of these things
where they sort of come to terms on how
in the world could we possibly fix this
get things back to the way that they're
supposed to be so we have our domain you
have your domain and that's effectively
it the other part of this is we get one
of the coolest moments when it comes to
like ultimate Hulk fighting main Marvel
Universe Hulk and that's one of the cool
things that did come out of ultimate
into a degree was that it was sort of a
love letter for like all the different
little battles and things that we'd
wanted to see over the years but never
really saw why like who would win in a
fight ultimate Hulk main Marvel Hulk
which one of the two is the strongest
that kind of a thing the way this kind
of played out though is that you ended
up having main Marvel Universe Bruce
Banner who was just kind of continuing
his experiments and Research into like
dimensional riffs and so on and so forth
kind of uh the other half of the
equation from what both Tony Starks were
doing but the ultimate Banner showed up
to meet him and as the two of them were
talking you actually had this kind of
disagreement between the two which was
surface level at best and it was is a
reason for Benders to have these guys
start fighting each other which was
awesome like it was really cool for what
it was but the entire basis behind their
disagreement is sort of an argument of
futility right that Ultimate Universe
Bruce Banner is very very just cynical
right and he is in a lot of ways a
nihilist just by virtue of him seeing
the Incredible Hulk Persona as more of a
curse than anything else he just kind of
believes life is meaningless right
there's no point in continuing on and
really even no point in anything at all
the difference here though is that
Banner from the main Marvel universe is
a lot more hopeful now a lot of this is
because of what was going on with the
character of The Incredible Hulk at this
point in time specifically Jason Aaron's
run which gave us a kind of reworked
version of Professor Hulk and so it was
kind of uh more powerful but also
equally intelligent version of the
professor Hulk that we'd seen in years
past which was basically a Hulk with the
mind of Bruce Banner right this that
kind of a thing but with the two of
these guys having totally different
viewpoints that ultimately the cynicism
of Bruce Banner from the Ultimate
Universe just gets the better of
literally me Marvel Universe banner and
it refers to Ultimate Banner as a coward
and that leads to like tempers flaring
the two of them fighting and then
literally like main Marvel Universe Hulk
just like sends ultimate Hulk flying
through the raft prison right Riker's
prison where like all the super powered
beings in that area are being held it
literally just causes a riot and one of
the people who just starts inciting
their wrath on everybody around there is
the Punisher which is amazing because
this Earth 616 Punisher right the main
Marvel Universe Punisher this guy
survives this guy made it out which is
awesome honestly I'm not 100 sure how I
agree with that because during like the
secret Wars or maybe it was The Punisher
last days I want to say it was Secret
Wars though Secret Wars issue number
zero when the world was ending The
Punisher like shows up in a bar where
you have all these villains and he's
just like he's like Such a Pity it's the
end of the world and I have all these
bullets what am I gonna do with them and
he kills every villain in the bar he
just sprays them all down mercilessly
but the thing about this is that he
actually ends up meeting his Ultimate
Universe counterpart which is kind of a
funny thing because there's a a bit of a
fight between the two of them and then
main Marvel Universe Punisher just
seemingly comes out on top which is cool
right it's just one of these these cool
little moments here but again like what
you have here in a lot of ways is that
with tempers flaring with a lot of anger
and resentment and rage and just
frustration with this sort of
overcrowded environment right these two
realities cram together it was only a
matter of time before things went to pot
exceedingly fast and so what this does
pretty quickly actually is it leads to
just like an all-out almost kind of like
a mini Civil War among like the heroes
and villains within this reality itself
now those individuals who were focusing
more on the dimensional Rift and so on
and so forth they're kind of hands off
right they're kind of doing their own
thing but this massive Calamity and this
massive battle does not go unnoticed and
in fact there's a point where
effectively Valeria ends up approaching
Doctor Doom now the thing about this and
the reason why it's so important is
because within the realm of Secret Wars
itself and as far as Dr Doom goes one of
the things that he had done is he had
found an alternate reality version of
Susan storm Franklin Richards and
Valeria Richard and then adopted them as
his own in effect he stole the life of
Reed Richards Mr Fantastic that was kind
of his thing and that actually becomes a
major focal point towards the end of
Secret Wars and the reason why it ends
the way it does but Valeria being the
head of the Science Foundation right the
Future Foundation effectively approaches
him and says given our intelligence some
kind of a dimensional Rift was activated
within the Ultimate Universe domain and
that led to the Ultimate Universe domain
and the main Marvel Universe domain
combining into one and they're
continuing to experiment with this
despite being expressly told by your
Thor core to stop doing it now we don't
know exactly what's going to happen we
don't know what's on the other side of
this dimensional Rift there may be
nothing there could potentially be
everything they could reach a realm
beyond anything that we've ever
discovered the realm of gods right the
one above all who really even knows
right no one knows for sure and she says
but even within the group itself they're
split one half of the group believes
they should report their findings to you
the other half believes they should
continue operating in secret all the
while blissfully unaware here that we
know everything that they're doing and
so she asked him what was even the point
right Valeria asked him like what was
even the point of allowing this to
happen in the first place of putting two
realities so close together knowing that
at some future point in time they were
going to end up combining by whatever
Manner and whatever means and then just
kind of sitting back and allowing
complete and total pandemonium to unfold
now there's a reason for this and we'll
talk about why this reason exists in the
first place because what it does is it
ties into the original version of battle
world that Dr Duma created before he had
wiped everything out and started over
again and so where Valeria asked like
where Dr Doom doesn't answer her and
Valeria asks do you want us to step in
do you want us to do anything like you
know doctor Doom's response is no right
like do not do anything let things
unfold as they will and she asked the
question but what happens if something
takes place that we can't foresee
something that happens that changes
everything enter Miles Morales now this
is one of the most important parts of
this story and the reason for this is
again when the Multiverse ended in
Secret Wars issue number zero that what
you had were these two kind of like life
wrath really one for what were
effectively the villains if you want to
call them that right the Ultimate
Universe version of Mr Fantastic along
with Thanos his coal obsidian and then
in turn you had the other raft for what
were basically the good guys Peter
Parker Spider-Man Miles Morales the
goodread richers from the main Marvel
Universe and a handful of others that
what had taken place here is that when
the Multiverse collapsed those rafts
actually just kind of existed out there
in The Ether and then ultimately arrived
on Battle world now there was some time
displacement hijacks and things like
that that we're not going to get into
the point being Miles Morales showing up
here he knows exactly what's going on he
understands exactly what's happening
here he knows everything is taking place
and he's about to spill the beans but
not necessarily in the most direct way
in fact he fires his webbing over
everybody and just says stop now
initially he goes to explain everything
but Emma Frost basically steps up and
says look as a psychic I can tell you
right now if you tell them everything
you know none of them are going to
believe you they're all going to think
you're crazy the only way for them to
know is to be shy own and so Emma Frost
uses her telepathic ability to basically
combine the minds or at least to project
the mind of miles into the mind of
everybody else here and that's when they
come into the realization of what's
going on now this is the explanation I'm
sure a lot of you guys have been waiting
for hopefully you guys find it
interesting so when everything was going
on with the multiversal collapse right
the beyonders and the molecule men and
all that kind of stuff that there was
basically a last-ditch effort by Dr Doom
and the molecule man Owen Reese and
Doctor Strange to defeat the beyonders
they did this by taking all the molecule
men that will remain from across the
Multiverse who were like these Universe
sized bombs literally when a molecule
man dies it blows up the whole universe
that what happened is all these molecule
men were basically just thrown at the
beyonders and blew all the beyonders up
and then eradicated basically all of the
Multiverse except for the main Marvel
Universe and the ultimate universe
itself and so that's what set these two
worlds on a collision course assuming we
ignore everything this bindis has been
doing with regards to the portal and the
dimensional Rift and all that kind of
stuff and so what what happened here is
that once Dr Doom had seen the beyonders
defeated he took the entirety of their
power then he created the first version
of battle world now it's not directly
mentioned here in the story but the
original version of battle world as it
was shown in disgust in secret Wars from
2015 was that it was a place of
suffering right it was just Only the
Strong deserve to survive those
individuals who were too weak were
perished it was like Warfare almost 100
of the time there was no light because
there was no sun and then Dr Doom
started to realize that this world was
destined to fail it was destined to fall
apart and So what had happened is that
he had completely reworked the entirety
of battle world just re-established
everything when Johnny Storm of the
Fantastic Four tried to fight him he
basically took away Johnny Storm's own
ability to control himself sent him out
into what you could call space kind of
the area orbiting battle world and
turned him into the Sun and so he lights
battle world now and battle world is had
basically become what it is now but all
this information is spilled directly to
ever everybody here by Miles Morales
that God King Doom is not some being who
has always existed and he's always been
God and he's all-powerful and you always
have to listen to him at one point he
was just a dude and then a team just an
insane level of power and used it to
recreate the entirety of the Multiverse
and sees absolute control over
everything and so once they all start to
realize what's going on then they all
realize okay now their main enemy is
Doctor Doom and so what is up happening
is they join basically everybody else in
the final fight against Doom over a doom
stat now that's actually covered in the
main secret War Story itself but the
funny thing about this is that with
everything going on what ends up
happening is that all these different
characters kind of start blinking out of
existence where they kind of start
disappearing the reason behind this is
because what's going on behind the
scenes is the conclusion of the story
where Reed Richards and Doctor Doom are
fighting and the molecule man takes the
power from Doom gives it to read and
Reed recreates everything so in effect
it's a reset right to a degree I mean
Marvel should have rebooted but they
didn't because because they were cowards
so basically everybody kind of vanishes
and things sort of go back to normal the
way that they were supposed to but the
reason why this is so important for
Miles Morales right it's one of the most
important things for his character when
he gets back to the Ultimate Universe
when he's sleeping he wakes up to his
mom now this is why this is so important
because his mom's dead right now there's
a whole reason why this happens and it's
the reason that you at least expect
right but Miles Morales gets his mom
back this sets everything going forward
into the future of the Ultimate Universe
miles and the main Marvel universe is
part of all new all different Marvel so
for the guys who are always curious how
it is that Miles mom came back to life
this was it right this is how she came
back it was a gift from the molecule man
Owen Reese for one of the coolest things
that Miles Morales ever could have done
it was phenomenal
okay so we are getting into uh
Spider-Man 2 and this is actually a
really cool story to me like it was a
really interesting story but people who
pick this up and rightfully so they
immediately compared it to Spider-Man
one and the reason why was because
Spider-Man 1 was in a lot of ways this
pretty significant story when it comes
to the Spider-Man landscape and the
reason why is is actually just the
nature of the history of Spider-Man so a
little bit of History here during the
mid 90s comic bust Marvel came up with
this idea that if they were going to
basically kind of experience the second
Renaissance of readership which is to
say regain an audience base they were
going to have to find a way to basically
take their existing superhero roster and
update it for the modern day the problem
is that Marvel's always had cold feet
when it comes to rebooting while their
continuity and their history is pretty
linear in terms of the fact that it all
follows a straight path the fact remains
it can be very confusing when it comes
to characters especially with things
like Spider-Man who have had three four
five different Publications over the
course of his entire history and so the
idea was that in the early 2000s under
Brian Michael Bendis Marvel launched
something called the Ultimate Universe
and the Ultimate Universe was basically
taking their existing Heroes and then
updating them for the modern reader so
Marvel kind of got the best of both
worlds they got a quote unquote reboot
of sorts while not actually rebooting in
the Ultimate Universe you got a whole
new set of stories all new Origins
events events transpired in different
ways now for Spider-Man in The Ultimate
Universe originally it was Ultimate
Peter Parker and it made sense I mean if
you were going to launch Ultimate
Spider-Man you had to start with Peter
Parker since he's so iconic that ran for
about 150 some odd issues and then
Marvel killed him off and the idea was
that they replaced ultimate Peter Parker
with Miles Morales which Bendis and
Sarah pacelli had made and so with Miles
Morales becoming the new Spider-Man
initially there was a lot of resistance
to it I mean you go back and you look at
old Forum posts you go back and you look
at old articles and a lot of people were
really against the idea of Miles Morales
for a variety of different reasons and
so the result was that where there was
some apprehension there in order to
basically kind of satisfy the readership
and to establish this in continuity
explanation that Miles Morales was here
to stay Brian Michael Bendis wrote a
story called Spider-Man and what
Spider-Man did is it basic basically had
a Mysterio I think it was find a way to
cross over into the Ultimate Universe
from the main Marvel Universe this of
course brought Peter Parker Spider-Man
from the main Marvel Universe and he met
Miles Morales for the very first time
and it was basically miles explaining
his whole history to the main Marvel
Peter Parker how the ultimate Peter
Parker died and so on and so forth and
it was the main Marvel Peter Parker
giving his Blessing and saying while
everybody else may question the fact
that you should or should not be
Spider-Man I'm okay with this and so it
was basically Marvel saying shut up
Miles Morales is going to be here for a
while and so he's been here ever since
you know and as time progressed you know
because of the fact that Marvel didn't
really give the readership a choice
people just basically began to grow on
Miles Morales but the fact remains here
that with miles in this scenario
following the events of Secret Wars 2015
Marvel basically canceled out the
Ultimate Universe and they basically
brought miles and Peter into the same
Universe Marvel Prime is what they call
it now now it was not a reboot there was
no re you know no no new origin for
miles or anything like that things just
kind of continued on so you could
literally start with ultimate Miles
Morales Spider-Man and then just read
all the way through to Secret Wars and
then pick up with one all new all
different Marvel and it's one seamless
story it just keeps going on as if it
never stopped and so the result is that
a lot of the themes that went on with
Miles and his Ultimate Universe stories
continue on in all new all different
Marvel Marvel now and Marvel Legacy and
so on and so forth in the sense that
he's still just a kid trying to deal
with the fact that he's Spider-Man that
he's got abilities now over the course
of the publication histories with
stories like spider-verse by Dan slot
things like that it's demonstrated the
fact that Miles has really kind of
coming to his own and he's really
growing comfortable in his own skin so
to speak with regards to being
Spider-Man but it does create a bit of
tension here because in a lot of ways
Peter Parker looks at where he was as a
teenager and he looks at Miles Morales
and says Miles Morales is where I used
to be and so he's really been this kind
of guiding force in terms of helping
miles along the way navigating these
uncharted waters in the life of miles
with regards to being Spider-Man
different things along those lines so
it's very much a mentor Protege
relationship between the two but with
the story picking up about a week before
the present day so to speak at the time
the story is being written initially
just kind of you know follows up with
this idea of just some massive surge of
energy that really kind of explodes in
the city of New York it is kind of
interesting because at that point it
switches over to the Brooklyn Visions
Academy of course work Miles Morales is
going to school and he basically ends up
meeting a girl named Barbara now Barbara
Rodriguez has kind of been a girl that
miles is interested in but hasn't really
noticed her too much the result is that
where Genki kind of plays wingman
basically and really kind of ropes in
Barbara Rodriguez and helps to introduce
the two of them together it's
immediately obvious there is a budding
romance between the two and that's the
cool thing about this is that when it
comes to the Spider-Man Legacy it's
always the idea of stepping into that
role of developing relationships between
two characters for Peter Parker
originally it was Betty Brandt that it
went into Gwen Stacy then it went into
Mary Jane Watson of course which ended
with Spider-Man one more day and he's
more or less kind of been single ever
since there was that one girl he was
dating during big time but that didn't
last too long and so of course again it
is pretty interesting in terms of this
whole idea with Miles because it does
set the stage for future stories now
remember this is Brian Michael bennis's
last story on Spider-Man it's the last
the last thing he's writing here so
again we're not going to see a whole lot
coming out of this it's whatever future
writers choose to do if they choose to
do anything thing at all now of course
in the middle of this this idea of Miles
trying to spit some game on Barbara we
end up having a giant robot head that
crashlands he basically ends up pairing
up with Peter Parker and the two of them
go to poke around and see what it is is
happening now ultimately what ends up
taking place here is that this Rift is
like a portal of sorts where it leads to
we have no earthly clue but it does
result in the arrival of Taskmaster now
we have talked about Taskmaster
specifically we talked about him with
regards to the whole idea of rolling
Deadpool over into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and different things like that
but Taskmaster is really one of the most
dangerous villains who exists out there
well he's kind of a villain kind of not
he's really more of a middleman
sometimes he helps out Heroes sometimes
he helps out villains he'll do almost
anything you want to if you pay him
enough money to do it of course he has
been sent on a mission here and we'll
find out what that mission is in this
whole scenario it kind of deviates for a
second and it picks up at a place called
Bloomfield Hills and the reason why this
matters is because a man who's walking
his dog whose face is scarred is
addressed by a woman who refers to him
as Miles Morales and so this is huge
because what this does is this
introduces a second version of my miles
into Marvel Comics which is somebody
that we haven't actually seen before now
of course switching back over to
Taskmaster this is interesting because
Taskmaster is probably the best fighter
in Marvel Comics to be honest I would
argue Taskmaster is better than like
Wolverine probably better than than
Captain America because Taskmaster has
developed his fighting skills in such a
way that if he fights an opponent long
enough he'll basically become their
fighting style and he'll actually be
able to predict what they do before they
do it but the issue with this is that
whatever Mission task Masters been on
he'd basically been sent on that mission
by this other version of Miles Morales
scarred miles is you know we'd probably
get away with calling him that so it is
kind of an interesting Mission here
because remember for Miles more hours
Spider-Man a lot of the stuff that goes
on with regards to the various Heroes
he's fighting is new to him in the
Ultimate Universe he was relatively
familiar with all the things that went
on with the various enemies that were
there different things like that but
because of the fact that a lot of the
characters from the main Marvel Universe
were revamped and reworked in the
Ultimate Universe when secret wars
happened and he was moved over to the
main Marvel Universe characters like
Taskmaster as he existed there is not
really someone miles is familiar with
and so he's not really used to the kind
of trickery the kind of deception the
Taskmaster uses I mean in this instance
for example miles goes to attack
Taskmaster and is basically shocked by
the suit that he's wearing it's just not
something he expects the other half of
this is that Miles his whole you know
instigation for attacking Taskmaster is
due to the fact that with Taskmaster on
the phone he basically said that he's
answering to a guy named Miles Morales
and what this does is this brings Miles
Morales Spider-Man into the mindset of
asking the question who's this other
version of Miles what in the world is
going on now Peter's initial response
here is to kind of dismiss it to a
degree and the reason why is because
following the events of Spider-Man one
of the first things that Marvel did is
they had the main Marvel Universe
version of Peter Parker look up his own
version of Miles Morales which as far as
this story is telling us didn't exist
instead all you had was just miles from
the Ultimate Universe and that was
really about it now of course there were
a few things that went on behind the
scenes but the idea of Peter is to say
look Taskmaster fights in a variety of
different ways the longer you fight him
the more like you he becomes just take
my lead listen to what I tell you and
everything will be fine but it's very
dismissive Peter doesn't really try to
get in the head of miles it's just kind
of like hey man look this is how the
game gets played all right he's probably
messing with your head it's what
villains do you know just move on don't
read too much into it but if you're
Miles Morales and you come from a
universe that doesn't exist anymore
you're still gaining your bearings with
regards to the universe you're currently
in and then suddenly somebody references
another version of yourself your
immediate instinct is to say what in the
world is going on this is kind of cool
because what we end up finding out here
is that where Peter was initially
dismissive instead he followed up behind
the scenes and what he did is he
actually went to Jessica Jones which is
cool because of course miles and Jessica
have met before but Jessica Jones is is
really kind of like the premier
detective in Marvel Comics but she's not
Batman level but she's a really really
good detective in terms of getting the
kind of information she needs I mean for
example when she was originally
introduced she figured out Captain
America's identity as Steve Rogers which
was being kept hidden from the general
public for quite some time now also
remember it's not an accident she's in
this story Brian Michael Bendis made her
and so if this story is going to be kind
of like Brian Michael business's swan
song to all the different things that
he's done on then it makes perfect sense
to grab two of the most iconic
characters he's made and kind of throw
them together in the same story even if
it's not for any real measure of time
while Jessica Jones is here it's
explicitly for the purpose of Peter
bringing miles over and saying I had
Jessica do as much research as she could
she's dug up some dirt she's talked to
all these different people and she came
back with nothing there's no one out
there named Miles Morales as she's aware
of and if there is someone out there
named Miles Morales no one knows
anything about him and so what this
story does is it basically grabs the
idea that yeah I mean we know there's
another version of Miles Morales out
there they're trying to find out who he
is but maybe the guy is just so well
hidden he doesn't want to be found and
if he doesn't want to be found then the
question is why well fortunately for us
Brian Michael Bendis gives us this
backstory to a degree he doesn't go
super in depth he gives us just enough
to really kind of satiate this line of
questioning that we have
what we end up doing here is jumping
back several years ago to the early days
of Wilson Fisk and this is interesting
because when it comes to Kingpin there
really isn't a whole lot known about his
past in fact there's really nothing
there in terms of An Origin there's no
like game pin number zero where there's
there's no line of stories called like
The Life and Times of Wilson Fisk but
what this also does is it feeds on
Daredevil The Man Without Fear now
Daredevil The Man Without Fear was a
series that was written in 1993 I'm
pretty sure and it focused really kind
of on the nature of Daredevil himself
but the idea here is that it offered
this explanation that back before Wilson
Fisk became the Kingpin that he
basically served as an enforcer for a
guy named Don Rigoletto and Don
Rigoletto was just the guy who was
running the mob scene before King
pendant now eventually Kingpin kind of
rose to prominence and replaced Don
brigaletto but at the time you know this
little bit of a story right here with
regards to the to Spider-Man 2. this
really kind of picks up during the
events of Kingpin being an enforcer for
Don Rigoletto now of course like any
depiction of prison life with regards to
Marvel Comics as soon as Kingpin gets in
there it's immediately establishing he's
not a guy to be messed around with now
of course a lot of this is done for the
purpose of really kind of showing us
that the groundwork is being laid for
him to become the Kingpin which is to
say take over the entire crime scene in
Hell's Kitchen and throughout the city
of New York but we also end up having
this first encounter between Wilson Fisk
and this other version of Miles Morales
and what we end up finding out here is
that this other version of Miles Morales
is of course much older but he's
basically serving a prison sentence to
cover for somebody else but because it
seems to have been done either as a
favor or as just something of his own
accord but in some form or fashion
benefits don rigoleto don Rigoletto
basically sent Kingpin into prison for
the purpose of showing his appreciation
to Miles Morales and essentially saying
you're going to be taken care of after
this now the other half of this is
forming a relationship between Kingpin
and this other version of Miles and the
reason for that is because this other
version of Miles have basically been
contracted by one of the guys to take
out Kingpin and so it's basically
building trust between the two of them
now keep in mind when it comes to Wilson
Fisk earning his trust is a very very
difficult thing to do but when it's done
you have it forever and he will do
virtually anything you ask so long as it
doesn't cost him what's important to him
or it doesn't challenge his ability to
rule over the crime scene in New York
now this friendship that forms between
the two of them is huge in a lot of
different ways because where Kingpin is
you know more or less taking a shower
and then ultimately met by one of the
guys that tries to kill him instead what
ends up happening is Miles just kind of
shows up out of nowhere and kills this
guy this truck or really you know
attacks this guy that's trying to kill
Kingpin ultimately ends up killing him
of course it results in this older
version of miles or this other version
of Miles receiving scars which is why
his face is scarred in the present day
in the first place but the fact that he
stepped in and he saved the life of
Kingpin is a very big deal because this
is one of those things where Wilson Fisk
does not forget but because of the fact
that Wilson Fist and this other version
of Miles had formed such a strong
friendship together what they've
basically done here is they've kind of
gone out and formed off their own little
branch of criminal activity and their
actions do not necessarily go unnoticed
but in the end term what ends up
happening is this other version of Miles
this is scarred Miles Morales falls in
love with a woman named Barbara and this
is cool because with the whole the
really the two of them meeting one
another kind of having this conversation
it does show the idea of a better life
and that's ultimately what begins to
come to fruition here now of course in
the interim we end up having Wilson Fisk
and the scarred miles making their move
against Don Rigoletto basically taking
over his Empire and killing him in the
process but the fact remains in a
conversation between the two which is
probably one of the coolest
conversations that I've read in comics
in a long long time is basically the
scarred miles wanting to get out of this
life now remember this is part and
parcel to the nature of the characters
for Wilson Fisk because he is so
synonymous with being the Kingpin it's
always basically been alluded to that
he's always longed to run the criminal
Empire or at the very least to have this
extreme level of power when it comes to
political influence and different things
like that to have his will be done and
so because of that it was always one of
these things where it's like he was
destined to become the Kingpin but for
the scarred version of Miles he was kind
of thrown into a situation he wasn't
really ready for it he's not really sure
this is what he wants to do what he
wants is happiness and that's the
coolest thing about this is one of the
reasons why I love love love love Brian
Michael Bennis when it comes to
developing characters because he focuses
so much on the motivation of the
character more so than them just
fighting people now with this scenario
scarred miles wants to basically marry
Barbara this blonde woman he went on a
date with he wants to take her hand he
wants to take his money and run and he
wants to be gone he wants to be away
from all this he wants to find some
small measure of peace and that's what's
cool it's because Wilson Fisk says then
it shall be done if that's what you want
then that's what will happen it all fits
into the idea that as long as you'd
maintain his trust as long as you don't
betray him he'll go to the ends of the
Earth to make sure that you want for
nothing the problem with this is that
somewhere along the line and for reasons
that are unexplained Barbara had died
and what this effectively did is it
stripped this older version of miles
from almost his entire world lift he had
no real desire to continue on in his
mind is just kind of giving up now this
is a very very very important
conversation because what this does is
it stems from the nature of Wilson Fisk
and his wife Vanessa now in Marvel
Comics uh Vanessa had basically killed
her own son just because of the fact
that her son Richard was trying to take
out Wilson Fisk the problem was that she
was suffering from a disease at the same
time and it really just kind of resulted
in Vanessa kind of losing the will to
live eventually dying but the idea
behind this is that Wilson Fisk
basically says I tried every form and
every piece of technology and everything
out there I used almost every resource I
had to find a way to basically bring
Vanessa back I learned that there were
alternate universes there were alternate
Dimensions but I found satisfaction in
knowing that there had to be another
version of her out there basically it's
Wilson Fisk saying you will not be with
Barbara the way she is you know the way
that you remember her that version of
Barbara is gone but you can find some
measure of comfort in knowing that there
is a barber out there somewhere who is
finding happiness that if there is a
Multiverse then in other universes
somewhere you and Barbara are happy
together now where this is no real
measure of comfort for a while just
because of the fact that he's looking at
the moment saying I don't care about you
know the possibility that there might be
alternate universes what I care about is
the here and now at the end of the day
it is Wilson kind of reaching out to his
friend and trying to help him find a way
to essentially deal with this whole
scenario now of course what this does is
it kind of moves up you know back to the
modern day picking up with Spider-Man
Miles Morales as well as Peter Parker
now of course this leads to Miles kind
of going about his nightly routine so on
and so forth and then eventually
summoning across the actions of a
Taskmaster who's doing whatever it is
that he's doing and of course you know
miles following him along the way this
ultimately brings in the whole idea of
Peter Parker really showing up and
referencing the events of Spider-Man 1
and the first time he and Miles met each
other and this is really cool because
what he does is kind of impart these
words of wisdom to Miles again really
playing out this Mentor relationship
where miles is you know youthful uh that
really plays itself out in a variety of
different ways one of the things to
notice here is that while miles has
struggled and where Miles has you know
lost uh important members of his family
at the end of the day he hasn't really
experienced it on the same level as
Peter Parker with Peter Parker he lost
Gwen Stacy in the night when Stacy died
because of a moment of recklessness the
death of Uncle Ben different things like
that those all went towards the idea
that Peter Parker basically learned over
the course of his life that you can't be
Reckless if you have the ability to act
you have the responsibility to act
different things like that Milestone is
still learning a lot of those lessons
and so that's really kind of Peter's
response to this is you know hey look
with great power comes great
responsibility stop being Reckless if
there are answers out there the answers
will come in time and this really kind
of comes to fruition in the sense that
with regards to task master board in
this plane once mile sees what's
happening he kind of you know kind of
shouts out no uh Taskmaster of course
hears him and blows up the building that
Peter and miles are on now of course
this leads to a direct battle between
Taskmaster Peter and miles or at least
it seems to the problem is they're
knocked unconscious and the scarred
version of Miles simply says let's go
the Trap the Kingpin always falls into
is he has to stop Spider-Man he's got to
be the one to win we're not even going
to worry about that we've got a goal so
we're just gonna leave him here we're
not going to waste our time with this
that's one of the things you guys notice
you know when it comes to business and a
lot of comic book stories you'll see
these tropes right you know it'll be
like okay now that I've got you tied up
let me explain the entirety of my plan I
will give you all the time I'm the world
to loosen your grip when you know I'm
done explaining my plan it will
conveniently happen at the same time
that you've freed yourself and then I'll
be defeated you know it's one of those
things where it's like why didn't the
villain just shoot the hero in the face
but what we end up finding out here is
the mission Taskmaster was sent on by
this scarred version of Miles was to see
if there were different universes out
there one of which held a version of
Barbara and the answer to that question
is yes there is another Universe out
there that holds a version of Barbara
that this scarred version of miles is
looking for in response to this this
also picks up with a plane taking off
Taskmaster basically making his return
and facing off against miles and Peter
now this is kind of cool because what
this does is serve as a distraction of
sorts you know where Taskmaster is just
there to keep you know Miles Morales
Spider-Man and Peter Parker distracted
while scarred miles goes off and does
his own thing and it works because of
course when this portal is open and when
he begins stepping through miles
Spider-Man kind of pops up and says look
what's the deal with you my name is
Miles Morales too tell me what's going
on give me an ending to this story the
problem is that Miles doesn't get one
and that's the interesting thing here
because where he shot through the
shoulder Taskmaster ends up making his
Escape you know Miles Morales Spider-Man
Peter Parker emerged from the rebel and
Miles Morales Spider-Man's angry because
there's no resolution here but Peter
Parker's responses and that's usually
how it goes there's not always a
resolution sometimes you don't find out
what the motivations of the villain is
the villain just gets away and you never
find out why they did what they did you
never find out what the secret behind
them was sometimes there is no great big
huge master plan that's one of the
things that Miles kind of has to learn
to deal with and it's one of the things
that Peter Parker is passing on to him
but sometimes it's not necessarily the
heroes beat the villain and ride off
into the sunset sometimes a villain just
runs off and that's really about it it's
very you know realistic in terms of How
It's depicted different things like that
but what we end up finding out here is
picking up with scarred Miles Morales of
course arriving in this alternate
universe this alternate reality he of
course kind of walks into a bar and
finds that Bar's version of Barbara it
allows him to kind of reconnect to
regain this life he was looking for now
in the middle of it all we end up having
you know this massive explosion
different things like that and in
response to that of course is this
alternate reality version of Spider-Man
and I think you guys understand what
direction the story is going in because
this also diversion of Spider-Man
fighting against some Force you know
looks up to the rest of the people who
were there and what we find out is this
is the Ultimate Universe the Ultimate
Universe is still exists
the Ultimate Universe is back guys
that's how the story ends it ends with
the return of the Ultimate Universe now
the question is what does this mean for
Marvel Legacy what does it mean for
example with like this version of Thor
still in existence what does that mean
for like warthorpe I have no idea that's
this is Brian Michael Bennis at his best
well I really want to bring back the
Ultimate Universe so done Ultimate
Universe is here and all the characters
you're familiar with with the Ultimate
Universe are here but what about like
Thor this is Brian Michael business at
his best he wants to do it so he's gonna
do it and that's just the way it is
there's no explanation of how Thor fits
in with anything else how Ultimate Iron
Man fits in with anything else there's
no real explanation in terms of how this
fits in and there you know of course
it'll be after Brian Michael Bennis is
gone it'll be some other Rider that has
to pick this up and basically try to
find a way to work this in to the rest
of the larger Marvel landscape so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
Rob cork if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later
peace